All right, good morning.
All right.
And everybody wishes they were on vacation, just got back from vacation or just leaving for vacation.
I now call the July 10th, 2019 meeting of the State Board of Education to order.
I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Vice President Strauss, will you lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Thank you.
I'd like to start with some good news.
California recently received news that the Perkins V transition plan that the state board approved at our May 2019 meeting was approved by the Federal Department of Education.
We're delighted that the work continues for development of a full plan.
And in bittersweet news, this is student board member Cardenas' last meeting.
We wish her well as she begins her studies at Stanford University.
And we have a little certificate and a card that I would love to present to you.
But before I do, are there any comments you'd like to share, Hema?
Thank you so much for this opportunity, first of all.
It was a real honor to be on this board because, you know, growing up, I never expected myself to be in a position that would impact a whole state that I lived in for, you know, I was born here, so since I was little.
And, you know,
When I'm doing this work, the people I think about the most is my little siblings and my Oakland community.
You know, I'm a proud Salvadorian Mexican East Oakland girl.
You know, I take that wherever I go, you know, East Oakland's my city, you know.
And so when I'm doing this work, I always think about what students don't have access, you know, because there's always things that are happening in communities that people don't talk to.
You know, when we're doing this work, as much as we like to celebrate all the amazing things we did this year, you know,
looking at the accountability system for the dashboard, you know, the health education framework, looking at these different things.
It's also another reminder that we have so much more to go because, you know, as we do this work, there are students who are getting harassed by security guards at their schools.
There are students who are not getting dropped, who are not dropping out.
They're getting pushed out by their teachers who don't believe in them.
There are students that are running out of paper, which I've experienced.
And so, you know, when I carry and doing and I continue to do this work, those are the stories I remember, because, you know, every success has something forward to go to.
And so, you know, I always think about my little sister, Vida, who I'm always so proud of.
You know, I like to show off that like she's taking
classes at UC Berkeley, even though she's still in middle school.
And, you know, I'm really proud of her for that because I feel that every student should have that opportunity.
Every student should have access to those things.
And so I'm really excited to see how this board does after.
I'm very excited for next year's student board member, Brenna.
And yeah, I really appreciate this.
Thank you all again so much.
I'm excited to see what's going on.
And we have here this lovely certificate and a card for all of us.
Can I play mom?
Yes, we'd like to get a picture.
You know, we would all like to have a picture with her.
I'm just saying.
I live right on the Stanford University campus, so we'll trade numbers before we leave today in case, so you have a mom away from home.
Yeah.
That is probably true.
But there are those moments.
There are those moments.
So there's a handout on the table in the lobby identifying the proposed items on the consent calendars.
The proposed regular consent items are items 5 and 7 through 13.
The proposed waiver items are W01 through W15, 17 and 19.
And I'd like to remind board members that any members wishing to remove any items from the proposed consent calendar should advise our executive director, Karen Staff Walters, by 10 a.m.
today.
We'll take up the waiver consent items and the regular consent items early this afternoon.
With respect to public input, letters from the public on matters before the board were aggregated and are filed in an electronic folder sent to you by board staff last week.
We appreciate the public's continued cooperation in emailing all meeting related correspondence to the SBE office at SBE at cde.ca.gov last week.
Speakers should sign in at the table just outside the room.
Binders are on the table with separate pages for each item number.
Signing in on the page that identifies the item number on which they would like to speak will help ensure that we keep track of all the speakers for each particular item.
Item 15 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on items that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
Public comment will be limited to 1 minute per speaker.
In order to ensure that everyone gets their 1 minute, there's a timer at the podium that will flash a red signal to each speaker when the 1 minute time limit has been reached.
If anyone wishes to submit materials at the meeting, they should provide at least 25 copies to Amy with the item number that it pertains to clearly indicated.
Please do not give the information directly to.
Speakers who may be members of the audience or staff are asked to introduce themselves and the organization they represent prior to speaking if applicable.
Brevity will be greatly appreciated.
Please do not repeat comments that have already been made stating that you agree with the previous speaker or the comments made by so and so will be understood and noted.
And I will know for the board itself, we are having a 1 day meeting today.
There are, I know some folks who have to catch specific trains and planes at.
Close to around 4 this afternoon, so we're going to try to run a really tight meeting.
And try to limit our comments to the key points and be.
Succinct and powerful, I'm sure and I will really try to keep us moving along so that we can.
Succeed in this attempt to have a 1 day meeting and to get all of our items covered.
Additional seating with TV monitors is also available in room 1103 around the corner and down the hall on the left and in room 1801 around the corner and to the right inside the personnel services office.
Board members, please turn your microphones on when speaking and off when not speaking.
Please speak into the microphone so that comments can be properly recorded as part of the proceedings.
And if you need to recuse yourself, please do so before discussion on that item begins.
So with all of those preliminaries, the board will now go into closed session to discuss and or take action on the following litigation as noticed on the meeting agenda.
Carrie K. V. State, Thrive V. SBE.
I ask that the members of the public please clear out the boardroom and turn off the microphones.
Okay, we are going to reconvene the public session.
And in closed session, the board discussed and or took action on the following cases, carry KB State and thrive the SBE.
And now I'd like to invite State Superintendent Thurmond to provide the superintendent's report.
Thank you, Madam President and members of the board.
Welcome back.
I hope that the summer has been treating you well.
I'd like to also start by adding and echoing the comments of the president, and thanks to board member Father Dines.
Thank you for your service.
I thought about what you said about you never thought you'd be in a role to shape such impact on the lives of others, and I hope that you recognize that this is just the beginning.
You serve well here.
I think you've represented your community very well.
I imagine your sister is quite proud
of the example that you are setting for her, for the students in Oakland and throughout our state.
I want to thank you for your keep it real attitude and for making sure that the student voice is always amplified, but also for being a sophisticated advocate for equity and making sure that that has been something that we talk about in everything that we do here.
I'm sure you'll do quite well at Stanford now that you have an on-campus member to look after you.
And just hope that you'll continue to stay in touch with us and share your perspective on how we support six million students in our state.
Good luck to you.
And if we can be helpful to you, please let us know.
Thank you.
As for the rest of the report, I do want to share with you, we've made some staff changes and you'll have copies of our new org chart at your seat momentarily if you don't already, or I think you do already.
We are welcoming some folks that you already know at CDE to new staff roles and then we're adding some new friends to the staff organization.
I wanted to let you know that Stephanie Gregson has been elevated to the position of Deputy Superintendent.
It is the branch that you knew as assessment that was led by Carrick.
We want to congratulate her and she'll be sworn in
confirm later today.
Sarah Neville Morgan, who will be taking over as deputy of the branch that includes early learning,
She is not here today, but will be confirmed at a future time.
We have some new division directors.
One you'll meet today, Dr. Denise Parnell, who will be taking over the division for improvement and accountability.
And Dr. Pradeep Kodamaru, who will be taking over the career and college transition division.
I should also acknowledge that congratulations to our board president who was confirmed by the Senate recently.
This is our 1st meeting partway.
Well, it well, congratulations.
Everything is a step having worked with the Senate.
That's a good thing.
This is the first meeting since the state chart task force has convened and you should already have received copies of the reports.
Many of you have lent your insights there.
Thank you.
We think it was a balanced recommendation on ways to approach reform.
Obviously, those conversations continue to take place in the legislature.
I want to also share that we hosted a panel on best practices and charter authorization and renewal on June the 26th to help lift up new ways to approach the conversations of authorization and renewal.
CDE hosted a job fair on June the 15th, attended by hundreds who are interested in understanding our classifications, how to make application.
This was held on a Saturday to accommodate educators, and I want to thank all the staff
Here at C. D. E. who helped to make that happen in June?
We celebrated C. D. E. S. L. G. B. T. Q. pride month.
And as we in our way of celebrating, we've had ongoing conversations about how to support staff and students in our, our staff here hosted a panel.
of parents of LGBTQ students to talk about the supports that parents need to support their students.
Our work groups continue to meet.
As you know, we have 13 groups dealing with everything from closing the achievement gap to our teacher shortage, to how we improve literacy, special education, and K-12 funding, just to name a few.
Those groups are wrapping up their reports and making their full recommendations imminently.
We have added a new work group that's focused internally on how we improve and strengthen the climate of our own workplace to make sure that all employees feel supported.
As I mentioned, our task force submitted its report to the governor officially on June the 6th, and we continue to work on the issues of authorization.
Good news on the budget, we've been tracking it closely like you, some 400 million dollars to early education, 646 million dollars to support students with special needs.
CDE saw an increase in its positions by more than 30, notably two for supporting our charter school oversight work, another position and a half for statewide homeless student supports.
Um, we announced a statewide literacy campaign.
It's really still in development, but we recognize that our districts need more support to support our students and their abilities to read.
The way we kicked off the campaign is allocating grants of over a 1Million dollars.
To 2 different counties where we identified both high need and strong infrastructure.
To address literacy needs, and that was the county office of education.
And the Riverside county office of education, both that we've worked closely with both that express a deep commitment to help lead the way and improving literacy in their communities.
They've got strong infrastructure that we can use to help them support other communities who wish to build strong literacy programs.
We continue to provide support to other counties in light of the most recent earthquakes in Kern counties and San Bernardino counties.
Staff has been involved in serving in response roles to support those communities.
They have school damages.
There have been other kinds of challenges.
and our facility staff has been in the operations center working on response to supporting these communities.
So this is some of the updates of the things we want to share with you.
I'm always pleased to take your questions and to introduce you to the new staff who you'll be working with at the Department of Education.
And with that, I submit my report.
Thank you so much.
And we're going to dive right into agenda item one.
Item one is the update on the implementation of the integrated local, state, and federal accountability and continuous improvement system.
And we'll be looking at the recommended actions regarding the implementation of a combined four and five year graduation rate for the graduation rate indicator, the application of the three by five color table to the college and career indicator,
and an update on the Federal Waiver and Identification of Schools Related to English Learner Progress.
That's a big mouthful and a lot of work, and it's gonna be well-represented by Cindy Kazanis of the CDE.
Cindy, please begin.
Thank you.
Nice to be here.
Cindy Kazanis, Director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division.
To get us started, I just wanted to give you a couple brief updates.
It's red.
You're not hearing very, very loud.
Okay.
A lot of microphones up here today.
Thank you very much.
So to get us started today, just a little bit of updates since the board item became public a week or two ago.
We just got back from Florida.
We attended, a group of us attended the National Conference on Student Assessment where we had a proposal that was accepted to present on the California School Dashboard.
So there were a set of other states that were excited to hear how we approach the dashboard in that the dashboard is not our state accountability report card.
Others have deemed their systems to be, so there's a lot more freedom around that.
I was joined by our contractor, collaborative communications to talk about the user design process we went through in the stakeholder input process.
And so I just wanted to let you know that we are on the national stage with our accountability system.
We are getting ready to gear up for what we're calling Dashboard Week, and we're looking at doing a week of activities through social media and others to get out the word about the dashboard as students start back to school, how to look at how your school is doing, how to inform the local planning process for the school year.
And then most recently, I know that the superintendent talked a bit about the state budget, but in our division we are directly impacted by a couple of things in a very positive manner.
We were provided two additional positions for the accountability system, which is very helpful for Jenny and her staff who run a tremendous amount of data in a very short period of time.
There was also ongoing funding provided for the dashboard to San Joaquin County Office of Education, who, of course, is our contractor for the dashboard.
And with that money for this first year, they are going to be able to translate the dashboard into three additional languages, to Mandarin, Filipino, and Vietnamese.
So we are very happy to be trying to reach more audiences, especially at the parent level.
And then finally, there is a one-time allocation for integration of the student accountability report card, rather, the school accountability report card and the dashboard.
So there is some technical pieces, again, back to San Joaquin County Office of Education, which of course is directly funded through the department to do that work.
So the budget has a lot of positive pieces towards the accountability system, so it's very exciting.
So we wanted to start the presentation by talking a little bit and actually showing you a live demonstration of the Dashboard mobile app.
I heard a couple of you have downloaded it.
If you haven't, you can either follow along on your own app or you can follow along with us.
We're going to take you into the app itself.
We have a new system here, so bear with me and let's see how this works.
So we have actually now a suite of apps in the department.
We started off with the California School app.
We've also been able to develop one on where to find meals in California.
And more recently, an app was released about our curriculum system, which you're going to hear about next.
But we're going to start off with the Dashboard app.
And what's a little different about this was this was not developed by the department, but it is being hosted by the department.
This was allocated, again, to San Joaquin County Office of Education.
So as you can see, it's our friendly home page with our graduates posted there.
And we can go right into looking at the audience.
OK, perhaps the folks in the back can bring it up for the audience.
So what you see, I think, on this screen is that, again, at the touch, you can go back and forth.
You can toggle, rather, between English and Spanish.
And we can bring up, actually, on that level, the state summary results, which we'll start with.
I am doing this on a phone attached to the computer.
All right, we're going to keep moving along and if the folks in the audience have downloaded the dashboard app, I am on the state summary page so you can follow along with your phone.
So we'll right up here.
So what's a little different, which we understand is the new way of looking at apps, is that you're swiping from left to right.
So we are going from left to right to look at each of the indicators.
What is built in at the bottom of the app, you see icons.
One of them says Overview, which is the one we're on right now.
The next one is Population.
academic engagement and climate.
So again at the touch of the population we learn a little bit about California's enrollment in our public school system which for this last year was 6.2 million students.
Actually this is for the
17-18 school year.
There we go.
17-18 school year we were at 6.2 million students.
We then can look through each of the LCFF categories and by the touch of the screen dot learn more you can see that simple description.
So what you see as far as functionality is very much the same as what you see on the desktop except
of the ability to navigate a little more discreetly.
So if we go into the academic indicator, and if we, let's look at our college career indicator, our newest one, we see again that the state as a whole is at 42%.
If we look at our view more details,
we will get into the various student groups and how each of them are doing.
So there's these buttons in between.
It's just a really nice, clean, sophisticated navigation.
So we released, the superintendent released this last week with a press release.
And I've heard that we have over 300 downloads of the app.
It is available in the
Apple Store, as well as iOS, for Androids as well.
So if you haven't downloaded it yet, this is the latest and greatest.
So we'll continue to think about different ways to display data.
We are not collecting data on where you're physically located.
Rather, we are going to be looking at data analytics on what are the most frequent searches.
Are they looking at state somewhere?
Are they looking at one of our larger school districts?
who's using the types of searches that are taking place and those reports that maybe aren't getting as much use, how can we update the look and feel of that?
So we will use that to inform further development of the app.
So with that, I wanted to turn it over to my new boss, Stephanie Gregson, the deputy superintendent for assessment, to take over and show you the curriculum.
So what's exciting about our new branch is not only do we have assessment and accountability, but we also have curriculum and instruction.
So we are integrated together.
So when you're looking at the dashboard and you're seeing your results on English language arts and mathematics, and you're thinking, hmm, what's going on?
What are we doing within those subject areas?
And you want to find out what the standards are for those content areas.
All you have to do is download the California standards application.
And that is this one right here.
And we have almost all of the standards within the app.
We are missing English language development and our California next generation science standards, because those are pretty complicated to put in the app just at this moment, but they will be coming in the next few months in the next iteration.
So in this app, you can search standards individually.
So you can choose to look at our new California art standards.
And all of the standards are broken up for search by their specific
So, in our California Art Standards, we are broken up by discipline.
So, you can search by discipline, sub-discipline, the artistic process, the anchor standard.
You can look at multiple grade levels at one time.
If you want to look at health education standards, same thing.
We have our content area and our overarching content standard.
So, you can search specifically within each standard.
But if you're in a grade level team and you have 4th, 5th, and 6th grade teachers together and you're looking at how to integrate your instruction, then you want to search all of the standards and maybe you're working on inference.
And so you type in the word infer.
And what will come up as you scroll down is all of the standards that have the term infer in them.
So you can look at computer science, our grade range came to.
The descriptive statement data can be used to make inferences or predictions.
So this is going to help our K2 teachers understand that they can utilize data within their math lesson or science lesson and they are also meeting a computer science standard at the same time.
And if you scroll down, world languages.
So, if you are working on integrating your instruction, this app can help you see all of the standards that are connecting.
We will be making enhancements to this to specifically show some of the ways that we can completely integrate our instruction with the standards.
That's just a little sneak peek.
If you are working as a department chair in mathematics and you want to see what's happening in the grade level below or grade level above you, you can use minimum grade.
So you can go to sixth grade and do a maximum grade of 12th grade and look at all of the standards that are within that grade level.
The great thing about our app is if you turn it this way, you can see it larger.
So our app has been out for about a month, and we do have over 1,200 downloads already.
So we're very excited about the high download.
And so we're hoping with this presentation, we'll have even more downloads.
So if you have any questions around the app, please don't hesitate to ask.
This was a collaborative effort between the Technology Services Division and the Curriculum Framework and Structural Resources Division.
And it was very exciting to work together as a team to make this happen.
So in particular today, a special shout out to Alan Nakahara and Harry Mayo and Dylan Reed for their help in allowing us to toggle back and forth with a phone showing you an app.
I think that's the first time we've done that here at the State Board of Education.
All right, so we may be your longest item today.
Sorry for that, but it is going to be, I think, an exciting one in which we are looking to, we're recommending, rather, that you implement a combined four and five year graduation rate for non-alternative schools for the California School Dashboard.
We also are picking up some work that we had intended to do
and planning to go along regarding the three by five color table for our college career indicator.
And then Shanine Coates is going to join me and take over and talk about the ongoing work with the federal government on our waiver and identification of schools related to our English learner progress indicator.
And then we just always close out with what we've been doing as far as outreach on the dashboard.
So this is an item recommendation before you.
As I mentioned, it's a combined four and five year graduation rate and the adoption of the three by five for the college career indicator.
So just as way of background, the graduation rate is turning into more than just the four-year graduation rate.
You actually started that effort when we adopted, when you adopted the Dashboard Alternative School Status graduation rate, which was, it's combined really four, five, six-year graduation rate, if you want to look at it in that manner.
And so I think, you know, when we look at the language used on the dashboard in describing the graduation rate, we've really tried to walk, to move away from describing it as when you enter ninth grade, four years later, you need to graduate.
You know, not everybody is on a four-year track.
And so with this, today is what we're looking at is looking at our five-year graduation rate options, which is allowed under the Every Student Succeed Act.
It was not something that we were able to do
bring to you forward for a recommendation when the state plan was adopted back in 2017.
But with the ongoing work and with your guidance, we are here today to make a recommendation.
So as a way of background, of our 1,300, approximately 1,400 non-alternative schools, so students serving high school students, 974 had graduates that were fifth year graduates.
I think a better number to hear about is that about 60% of those schools graduated one to three students.
These are really, really small numbers.
they're important.
A student has gotten over the finish line with a traditional diploma, which means something.
It's meant to mean something in our society today.
So that is really the ultimate goal, as opposed to dropping out or taking one of the alternatives.
So the fifth year graduation rate is something that affects almost 6,000 students in the class of 2017 were able to do.
So there's a couple of things to think about under the Every Student Succeeds Act because, of course, we do have some federal requirements that we need to adhere to.
So if it's included as a separate indicator, so if it's a standalone indicator, a five-year graduation rate versus what we have as our graduation rate, a more rigorous goal, long-term goal, is required to be set.
We have done research on what other states have done because, of course, everybody has an approved plan by now, so we are fully implementing, they are fully implementing their plans, and so we know that 24 other states have developed this combined rate.
It was included as an attachment in the agenda, and they use the same long-term goal for their four-year rate.
So the U.S.
Department of Education has approved, again, those methods for those states.
Just to shift over from goals to support, support under the Every Student Succeeds Act, there are three categories that we look at.
And this is done in succession.
So the first category we look to see is at all high schools, regardless of their funding mechanism, if they have a graduation rate below 67%.
Then for support, we're looking at lowest performing Title I schools, and then the additional target support really is the next piece, because we've combined TSI and ETSI.
So in terms of numbers, overall, we're supporting under the Every Student Succeeds Act, 1,471 schools.
For the CSI low graduation rate, it's 300 schools, and CSI low performing for Title I is 481.
And then the additional targeted support and improvement, it's 859.
So there are quite a bit of our schools that are being identified and supported under these measures.
So, we took a look at the impact analysis for the option that we're recommending.
So, I wanted to make sure that we brought this slide up front.
We are going to walk through each of the options though.
So, for the option that we're recommending, if we were to implement that option and we look back on rerunning, we would never do this, but rerunning the support
analysis or rather the support list for schools under ESSA, we would see 27 schools that would shift from that 67% threshold above that.
So they would no longer be identified.
So we do have, I do have a chart later on that shows you by each of the categories, but I just wanted to bring this again up front.
Of the schools that again were identified because of the 67%, majority of them
over majority of them were our dashboard alternative school status schools.
So our alternative schools are definitely the bulk of the schools that are being identified because of the under 67% graduation rate.
So of the 300, 221 again were DAS and 79 were the non-alternative schools.
So of the 79, again if this would have been applied you would have seen 27 that would have moved out of being identified.
Now they would get put back in the bucket, and if they were a Title I school, we would look at them for the other CSI, and then again, ATSI.
So the rate that we're talking about today, again, is limited to traditional schools.
I just want to make sure I say that.
I'm going to say that a couple of times throughout the presentation.
So under the former accountability system, because I know this tends to come up on occasion, because we did report out under it, under the Adequate Yearly Progress, we looked at five and six year graduation rates.
And what we found was there were no patterns showing schools were delaying students' graduation timeline.
So I know that's been a concern that's been raised here before, that certain students were being held back to allow them additional time to get to the finish line.
That wasn't what we saw, at least under the former accountability system.
And that the additional impact of the six year rate was minimal.
There are far fewer students that are taking that additional six year to graduate.
So we have taken you through a timeline in this slide about where we started with this and the various actions you've taken.
We have been working on this for a number of years.
Part of the issue that we have is we have limited data sets.
So we brought this forward to you last fall for action.
We decided, we recommended that we take the additional time
once we had the additional data set.
So keep in mind that we had to recalculate our graduation rate because of a federal audit.
So last year, we only had two years of data.
And of course, for the fifth year, you need that extra, you need an additional, you actually need three years of data because you have to, you're picking up, it's lagging.
So we have brought this to you on a couple of occasions, and even most recently in March, talking about the options that we were gonna be working on and bringing forward to stakeholders.
So just to go back to our alternative schools and the Dashboard Alternative School Status Schools, DAS, this does not apply to them, but I did mention verbally that that graduation rate takes into account students who
graduated within four years, five years, or six or more years.
So that is, it already is, again, the graduation rate is no longer the four year as we have been talking about for so many years.
It's become something that's a little more complex.
And so we're trying to give students every opportunity to get over the finish line and to graduate with a traditional diploma if at all possible.
So we looked into four alternatives.
And I'm going to walk through them briefly.
There is some math involved in some of them.
So those of you that like equations, we'll walk through the equations.
And those of you that don't can ignore those slides.
So the first option is one that you adopted last fall, which was simply to report out on the five-year graduation rate for informational purposes.
The second is calculating simple or weighted average for the four or five-year rates, and then the third is what we are recommending, a combined same-year, four- and five-year, and then the fourth, reporting both four- and five-year separately, and assign performance color based on the higher rate.
So it's a little more complicated as we move along.
So the first option, again, this is what you're seeing on the dashboard right now for informational purposes.
combines four and five year rate from a single cohort.
So you're looking at class of 2017, total number of four and five year graduation rates divided by the cohort from 2017.
So this is what you see on the dashboard.
I'm not sure that we have had a lot of hits on this report, truthfully.
It got released in spring.
We will be providing a companion report in DataQuest with raw numbers, with by school and by district, which is what you can access on the dashboard, except it's in percentages.
So I think over the next couple of months, I'm going to say this up front, we're going to need to spend some time on how do you display this data and what is meaningful to folks when you only have one or two or three students graduating and we're trying to be respectful and adhere to the law in terms of person identifiable
by personally identifying students, trying to be careful of that.
So I think, if anything, on this in general, we do have a design challenge, but we have met that challenge in years past on redesigning the dashboard.
So I'm confident we can overcome it.
But this is what districts are seeing now.
You can see this, again, at the school level, at the district level, and at the state level on the dashboard.
And this is what you asked us to include with your action last year.
So the second option is calculating simpler weighted average, which both averages combined two different graduation cohorts that we're looking at.
The example that we have listed here is class of 2018 graduates graduating in four years, class of 2018 graduates graduating in five years.
And for this analysis, what we found was that it wasn't quite the stablest option.
So 40% of LEAs had a negative difference.
They were doing worse, they were worse off, and really our intent in adding the five-year is to help improve
and give credit to schools and districts that are investing in students to, again, get over the finish line.
About 60% have positive differences.
And this is an example of the negative impact that a potential school would have.
So we have school A and school B, and you can see that school A started off with the class of 2017 with 84.5%, and their class of 2018 was 91.5, and you averaged it out, simple average, and it actually decreased their most latest graduation rate by a couple percentage points.
So a positive impact had, again, a positive impact of a couple percentage points in the right direction and got them over the finish line to the 90, 92nd percentile, at least for school A in this example.
So we talked about that there was not a clear pattern and that they do result in a lower graduation rate for a significant number of schools.
So based on conversations we've had,
with you all in the past and definitely with stakeholders, we don't want to introduce an indicator that's meant to, again, have a positive impact by design and have a methodology that doesn't support that.
So option three, which is the recommended option, is a combined rate.
So we're looking at all students who graduated in a year.
We're looking at, for this option, we looked at class of 2018, four and five year graduates.
We've added in the fifth year graduates who were supposed to graduate in 2017 and it gives again students who.
were stayed and earned their diploma, gives those LEAs and schools credit.
You see weight given to both the numerator and denominator, as you can see in this equation.
So the additional of the five-year graduation rate for 2017, you see in the numerator and the denominator.
And what that looks like in terms of a real-life example is a 0.2, for this example, increase in their graduation rate.
So this is the example that, this is the option that we are recommending.
What we did find as far as impact analysis was that it does have, we always saw a positive impact on schools.
We did not see a negative impact on schools.
We did see low-performing, we looked at low-performing schools and LEAs versus high-performing schools.
That's where the greater impact has been based on our analysis as well as charter schools versus non-charter schools.
and then small schools versus large schools.
So the greater impact for those groups, I think for some, may be very positive, but for every single school and district that supports a fifth-year program, we do see a positive movement.
You can see below that the graduation rate for student groups enhances for African-Americans, English learners, students with disabilities, and foster youth.
which you see on this chart.
So the biggest impact as far as percentages is on our foster youth.
They obviously have the most opportunity to improve from the rate of 59%.
But we do see some gradual movement for all students and then almost a percentage point for English learners and students with disabilities.
So, this is a slide that I'm picking up from talking about support.
So we're bringing it back to to how schools would be identified for support and including that 5th year for this option graduation status for the schools.
that we look at for identification.
This is how you get to the 2027.
So there are 26 schools that move from very low to low, and one school that moves from very low to medium.
So they move out of the red category for status for identification.
But you can also see the impact between low and medium, medium to high, medium to very high, and high to very high.
So you can see across the board on our five by five grid for status,
how this would impact and then how we would ultimately use that in our identifying schools for support under Every Student Succeeds Act.
So the final option is reporting both rates, assigning the higher of the two performance levels.
So this is a math exercise in itself, but it would look at, again, the graduation rates for the two separate cohorts.
So looking at 2018, four-year graduation rate,
class of 2017, five-year graduation rate, and using the five-year graduation rate in option one, combining them into a single cohort.
So here we have
some data on the LEA level information for this option.
So you can see for very high, an increase over the five-year graduation rate.
Actually, increase for high, it maintains.
And then medium, you decrease.
Low, you decrease.
And very low.
So the impact of option four.
is that you do see that some schools and LEAs have a lower graduation rate, which of course is something that you have not shown interest in in the past.
We do not see LEAs receiving a red performance level for their graduation rate, even though their five-year is below 67%, and schools not receiving comprehensive support under ESSA due to low graduation rates.
Option four was not something that any of the stakeholder groups found very much interest in.
And there's some additional data on the challenges.
I think part of it, a lot of it is around communicating about how this is calculated.
So here is the summary options for each of them.
We took these options to the California nutrition advisory group.
We have a stakeholder group for the local control and accountability for LCFF.
We took this to them as well.
We have taken it out into the field to select groups and
Option three keeps coming back as being something that resonates and meets the merit of what you've addressed as far as what you're looking for, which is to positively impact schools and districts.
The technology, or rather the technical design group also weighed in on it.
And as I mentioned, as far as communication challenges,
I think each of them has their own set of communication.
We're changing really what graduation rate means.
So we need to start probably using some different words to talk about graduating and graduating within not only a four-year period, but a five-year period, and again, for alternative schools whenever they're in grade 12.
So our recommendation is that we move forward on option three.
So I don't know.
President Darling-Hammond, if you want to pause for questions, or if you want to keep moving on through the presentation.
This is the end of this topic, right?
This is the end of this topic.
So let's please stop here, because our brains are full.
So Felicia, you want to get us started on?
I just want to say that I do think option three is the best of the four options.
I do have some concerns.
I support the notion of having an extended graduation rate.
The combined is giving me a little pause because when we're looking at non-alternative schools that would be otherwise in the 67% or below, these are the low percentiles would benefit the most from a combined methodology.
So I think that we would have to consider a way that we up the threshold, because I think that if you are at the 67% or below, you should automatically be identified.
And just 1% could bump you and you fall off the radar for comprehensive support.
The other question I have is around small schools, and the PowerPoint showed that there's a benefit, but I'm wondering what the benefits are, because if you add students from the fifth grade, from the fifth grade, sorry, tells you where my, my mind's with my kids.
If you add students from the fifth year cohort, then that could potentially bump a small school from the three by five grid to the five by five.
because you're adding additional students to the denominator.
And so I'm wondering if that could create a disincentive to graduate students if I know that by retaining students, I actually could face another, the five by five versus a three by five.
So that would be another concern.
And I also know that this will now, because our system's so integrated, anything we move here will have an impact on other indicators.
So, now this will be part of the and what does that look like?
I have no sense.
What the data shows, and it's only less than 2% of our students.
I get it.
I do think that we need to start tracking a little bit better.
For instance, I asked, what are the numbers of L students?
And from the total pool, it was 2064.
I asked what number of that pool is LTELs, and I couldn't get an answer.
I do think we need to track it a little bit carefully to see, are these students, and I'm looking at only ELs, are they LTELs?
Because that's different when you've been in our system for six to seven years versus somebody that's a new arrival.
And we would want to know that so that we have better sense of the decisions we're making.
But again, small schools, what does that mean in terms of bumping them to a five by five?
And could that harm them?
Or can that create a disincentive?
And also, what does it mean for CCI?
What does it mean for the College Career Readiness Indicator now that we're adding the five year cohort?
I'll start the conversation and then Jenny can weigh in on some of the impact analysis that was done.
I think it's important to keep in mind for the 3 by 5 grade, it's not just small schools.
You're looking at the total students that were enrolled in 12th grade or that are expected to graduate that year.
So it could have been my high school, which had close to 1,000 students, but they only had a graduation class of
148.
So it's a little, I think that three by five sometimes we get caught up with it only being for rural schools.
And for rural schools, of course, if you have 200 students in your population in a K-12 school, your class size or your cohort is going to be 30 students.
So that one or two students isn't going to make a change, right?
So it actually may be more in your medium to even urban settings that have
populations, again, closer to 1,000 or 800 to 1,000 students.
But did we do specific analysis around that or the impact to the college career indicator, Jenny?
Because I don't recall from
Yes, we did an impact on small schools and it really helped small schools, only because remember that most of the schools only graduated, 60% only graduated one to three more students.
But when you have a small number and you're adding in three or four or five students, that will make a bigger impact on the graduation rate.
So it was a
a positive impact on small schools compared to large schools.
Because when you're looking at one or two or three students in a large school, it really doesn't push up the graduation rate very high.
We also looked at how we were going to calculate for the CCI.
So what we will do is we will take all the students in the denominator, which will include the fifth year graduates,
and they will be included in our CCI calculation, which means now we have to pull five years of data so that we can go back and look at what the students did in their freshman year, the fifth year graduates, what they did in their freshman year.
So we can do that.
I've talked to my staff about that and they've already changed their program in order to incorporate the new grad rate.
Thank you.
And so the last, I think, comment was around the long-term English learner students.
And with the exception of the English learner progress indicator, that's not been a request of this board before.
So we can definitely consider that moving forward.
I think that you all know that for this year, long-term English learners for this past year is going to have a bit of a blip because we don't have two years of data for English proficiency.
So we are estimating an additional over 100,000 students being identified as long-term mute learners simply because they can't get out of that status because we don't have tiers of data.
So it may be prudent to start looking at how do we display that data on the dashboard and thinking about it for the 2020 dashboard as opposed to the 2019 dashboard since the data we know is off because of that.
the situation between not having two years of data for the proficiency test.
So I have Ting, Eileen, and Patricia.
Is there anybody else who's waiting to be on the list?
And let me just note that we will come back to this question of the threshold in the fall.
So I think today we're just restricting our vote to the nature of the grad rate, but your question about the threshold is an important one, and we'll come back to that.
as well as for the long-term grad rate after we've done some stakeholder review and some modeling.
So just want to let you know that's on the agenda.
Ting, you're next.
So my question begins where member Ortiz-Legon left off.
in regards to the CCI and I think I heard that the graduates in the fifth year for the CCI would be included so if they let's say met an A through G or those graduates would be part of the calculation of the CCI?
That is correct.
Okay.
They would be part of it because we want the denominator in the grad rate and the CCI to be the same.
right and I think that's good because a lot of times what I'm seeing you know and I know from the field I understand the concern around the disincentive or incentive if you will not to graduate students in four years but what I've seen more and more are students who especially those at risk
trying to graduate them with a higher standard, if you will.
Graduate them so that they're completing another CTE course or graduate them because they're not quite meeting the A through G requirements and wanting them to get another semester.
And I can tell you from the field, more and more, we're seeing students who are
stress, they're leaving, taking leaves of absences, hospitalizations, and they need the additional time.
And what I really see is not an extra fifth year, it's usually another semester.
And by the time that they're 17, 18, they are ready to go.
whether they got the diploma or not, they're ready to leave high school.
So I think just even keeping them in a little bit longer just so that they get that extra little bump, I would encourage us that we look at that and I would be in support of option three.
So first, I just want to thank the department for all the analysis and options.
I think it was complicated.
And at CPAG, there was a lot of conversation about this and really trying to, first of all, general support wanting the fifth year, just supporting what Member Sung was saying.
And those of us who've worked in high schools know not a lot of kids stay that fifth year because they are really ready to go.
Because I think with the federal cutoff, it's, it's August, or we can't count them in the 4 year graduation rate.
And so understanding and CPAC completely supported the idea and the incentive to do the 5th year.
The complication was the understanding of how we would report it.
The people understood what the 4 year and 5 year was.
And so I understand on the dashboard now.
You will be able to drill deeper and see that, but actually general support for the concept and the incentive.
So, because what we know is that kids that get in credit trouble getting credit trouble later in their high school years.
And so the alternative schools, continuation high schools, like, get the high school students that are in credit trouble.
have a short amount of time to try to catch them up.
And so the incentive to, in a lot of our small schools, alternative schools were in the red because of that reason.
And so as you talk to continuation high school leaders, they talk about the short amount of time and the fact that the high school sends them over when the kids are in major credit trouble and then they've got a really, and then they got in the red.
So I think there's general understanding that we need the alternatives for kids that have challenging
Complex issues that face them in high school, but also understanding that we need that time.
So, um, I just appreciate the support of the options and understand that the field wants to be able to report it in a way.
That's understandable with the data.
Well, I also want to add my thanks and my congratulations to your team and putting this.
Information together.
This has been a very long and technical Conversation I agree with board with board member Lee Cohen about the threshold question and I'm glad to know we're going to continue that Conversation.
I also support this option, but for a very different reason we're beginning as the as our dashboard has matured and as the level of sophistication of
in the field with using and understanding the dashboard elements continue.
There's been this slight shift on what we look at the dashboard for, and I even heard it today with the staff when you said,
so that people can look at the dashboard and see how their schools are doing.
If the purpose of the dashboard is to keep the focus on continuous improvement, we need to make sure we continue to model that we're studying and using the dashboard to understand what we are learning about the services the schools are providing.
And we don't see that in a more important way than what we see with combining the four and five year graduation cohort.
What does it take for high school districts to provide the support to their freshman students to make sure that at the end of their high school career they graduate?
And in the ways that the information the dashboard can collect about fifth year graduates
informs those decisions.
So I think it's the graduation rate is not about improvement.
It's not about how we're doing.
It's about what we continue to improve to provide the support for so students so that more students graduate, whether it's in year four or year five.
And we have to continue modeling the focus on using the dashboard to learn about school programs and to learn about school change.
so that it's not about how we're doing, but what we're learning and how that informs the decisions we make on what we provide to students.
We have to be using the dashboard, especially on the graduation rate, to do this combining really is a good model for doing that.
I wanna make sure that we don't make that mistake and slip into the how are we doing conversation rather than what are we learning about what schools should be doing.
Any other, I would just like to reinforce one point that I think was in the presentation, but just to be sure.
So this way of calculating the graduation rate is a little different than what the actual five-year graduation rate is, in the sense that if you had 95 out of 100 kids graduate, and the next year you had three more of those graduate, your increase would be from 95% to 98%.
But when you add the kids to the denominator, you end up with just a 0.1% increase.
So we all get that.
But for the public, it'll be important for us to do the straight up four year and the straight up five year grad rate as an additional piece of information so that it will match what they're actually experiencing and seeing in the schools.
And then this becomes a way to blend them for the purpose of identifying where schools are
what they need to do to improve, just to follow on that comment.
So just being sure that everyone's clear about that, and having heard from everyone here, I think we're ready to see if we have a motion.
Oh, the public comment, sorry.
We have a couple more pieces to the item, sorry.
We like to take this in phases, but we only have one motion.
You have one motion for the whole thing?
For the whole thing, yes.
Oh, my.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, maybe that would be a good idea.
Is that OK?
It's just a two-parter, right?
So we talked about the combined four- and five-year graduation rate.
And then we're going to add the other piece of the action is for the three-by-five grade for the college career indicator, which is a very brief part of this presentation.
But if we have different opinions about those, we might want to have two motions.
So I don't think we will necessarily.
So I think the board can split a motion if at the end that becomes necessary.
But the option is to hear it all.
You want us to hold it all in our brains until we get there.
All right.
It will be much shorter than that.
There's a cognitive science principle called chunking, which we are violating at this moment.
But that's all right.
OK.
Go ahead.
All right.
And do we want to take public comment at the end of these two also?
OK.
All right.
Very good.
Proceed.
OK.
So we're shifting the conversation to the application of the graduation, excuse me, to the college career indicator.
for small student populations.
So what member Ortiz-Lacombe brought up, but now we're looking at it for again for the college career indicator.
So what we note and we've noted throughout developing this accountability system
is that schools and districts with small student populations are more susceptible to large swings from year to year.
So the board has adopted a three by five grid.
What happens, what has tended to happen or can happen is identification in our extreme columns, so the red and the blue.
And the various indicators that we've looked at and that you've adopted over the past was graduation rate, suspension rate, chronic absenteeism, and now we're looking at college career indicator.
So what we do is, I'm gonna show you, I'll show you in a couple of slides the actual chart, but it condenses the five by five grid into what we call a three by five.
It removes the far left column and the far right column, the far left being decreased significantly and the far left, or rather right, being increased significantly.
You have taken prior action actually two years ago on the graduation suspension rate indicators and then last fall for chronic absenteeism.
So we are looking at a student group of 149 or less.
We talked a little bit through this, but you have the text here on this slide about how it's different for each of the indicators, because we look at different cohorts.
So for the graduation rate, we're looking at, depending on your action today, students in the four-year cohort or the DAS graduation rate.
For suspension rates, it's number of students that were cumulatively enrolled.
So that's again, applies to grades 3K through 12, and then the chronic absenteeism indicator, looking at number of students who met eligibility under the enrollment calculations, which, of course, has a minimum enrollment of, I think, 30 days is what we've adopted.
This is the visual.
Again, you still have lots of opportunities to get in the red, orange, yellow, green, and blue, but you're shifting everything in to lessen volatility for those smaller populations.
So there are still, again, the ability to get all those five colors, what we talked about.
Here's the impact analysis that we've done for this indicator, for the college career indicator.
And again, this was based on the four-year rate and then the DAS rate because we have not yet applied, we have not yet approved the combined four and five-year graduation rate.
So 2% of cases for LEAs are affected, 3.6% for schools, and then 6% for student groups.
What happens?
We see schools obtaining higher performance levels of just 2%, a positive change, and then student groups impact about 4.1%.
And the student group that most impacted that we noticed was homeless students.
So that is that piece.
I'm going to shift, unless there's questions about that, I can shift the conversation out to the final piece that I will defer to President Lyndon Arlingham on how you want to proceed.
I think we want to see if there are any questions on this piece before we go to the next piece, if that's okay.
Sue Ellen, do you want to add any comments as our liaisons?
Any questions about this?
All right.
And then we're going to, you want to hold public comment until after this, or are we going to do public comment now?
After this, if that's okay.
Okay.
Good morning.
That was my teacher voice.
It still works.
My name is Shannon coats, I'm the federal policy liaison here at the California Department of education and I'm pleased to present to you an update on the English.
Learner progress indicator also known as the LP.
So we essentially have two issues or matters regarding our ELPI, our English Learner Progress Indicator.
On one hand, we had the matter of our ELPI waiver request.
And then on the other hand, we have our ELPI state plan amendments.
And the issues essentially have converged into one resolution in our 2019 dashboard.
So with the matter of our ELPI waiver request,
In May 2018, with the support of stakeholders, California requested a four-year waiver from the U.S.
Department of Education.
And this was so that we could include our recently reclassified English learner students and our long-term English learner students in our LP calculation as an incentive to our local school districts.
This was with the support of a variety of our stakeholder groups.
including the TDG, our LP work group, et cetera.
So we received an initial denial from the U.S.
Department of Education in January of this year.
And then a California delegation went to Washington, D.C.
to present on our waiver and clarify a request.
And in April, we received the official denial of that waiver request.
And so, and I'll bring, I'll come back to this.
So, I just want to sort of lay the background for that issue.
And then we have our state plan amendment.
So, with this, as you know, California's state plan was approved in July 2018.
And California had been in contact with the U.S.
Department of Education
18 months to two years just to receive technical assistance as we transitioned from our old proficiency assessment, the CELT, to our new assessment, the LPAC, and to get their suggestions, their expertise on how to have a valid and reliable and technically sound LP given that transition.
And they provided us with their suggestions, which we discussed with national experts that they suggested to us and that we had already been working with.
We also discussed their suggestions with our technical design group, our LPE work group, and all stated that because of the differences in the test as well as the underlying standards,
for the tests that we were not able to pursue what Ed thought may have been possible in terms of the LP calculation.
So, in December 2018, California submitted a state plan amendment related to the LP.
And essentially, we were proactive in stating that we would have a second year
of comprehensive support and improvement and additional targeted support and improvement calculations, which would include LP status and would be based on the 2019 dashboard.
So, we know that this is the earliest time feasible to have an LP calculation that is reliable.
and valid, and the U.S.
Department of Education, after a bit of back and forth, which is identified in a June memo to you, submitted to us a Title I, Part A grant high-risk designation determination.
So, the state board president and the superintendent submitted a request for reconsideration of this designation, and these letters are also included in that June memo.
On June 27th, the superintendent and myself, as well as other CDE staff, went to Washington, D.C.
We held a meeting with some key staff at the U.S.
Department of Education, and they notified us at that time
during the meeting, but also in conversations after the meeting, that they are okay with our action plan to, not LP amendment, but our action plan to include the LP designations in our 2019 dashboard and to use those for the CSI, TSI determinations, and that they will lift the high-risk designation after we show evidence of completion of that task.
Also, just wanted to note that this designation does not impact any of the sub grants.
So, I did not float through those slides as I should have, but she, but, but that is the information.
I also wanted to point out that have been working with our LP work group meeting and regarding the.
The waiver, all have agreed that we've exhausted our options here, and so we're continuing on with the LP indicator formula without the special edition of our RFEPs and our LTELs.
And we're also trying to explore additional ways that we can provide that incentive to our local school districts, such as pursuing how we can include the LP in the determination for awards programs, such as California Distinguished Schools.
So that completes the LP update.
Are there any questions related?
Lisa?
Anyone else?
Thank you for this, and I know that the intent was to make this a very robust indicator.
It was never meant to mask.
So it's unfortunate that we were not able to get approval, but as we move forward, and this will come to us in September, November for a final vote, just want to encourage the department to have convenings and have stakeholder input beyond just the technical design group and the LP work group, because those are close groups.
And so I know that this has gone to CPAC.
There is an opportunity for public comment, but if we can make, maybe have some webinars or have other avenues to welcome public input, that would be appreciated.
We will, yes.
And we also have SSA stakeholder sessions, which we'll utilize for this purpose as well.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And just to close out, we've been active since we last met with you all in getting the word out about the dashboard.
We will be in Long Beach at the end of the month at the
MTSS conference and got invited for the second year in a row to the student guidance counselor group.
I don't remember the name of their association, it's long.
But they are very pivotal and I think helping us with the college career indicator and getting the word out about how do we make sure our students are on the right path to graduate and be successful after high school.
So with that, this is the action before you today.
At this point, if there's any public comment, we want to be sure to hear that.
We do have three speakers.
Would the following speakers please line up?
Dawn Cuppy, Martha Diaz, and Liz Gouin.
Thank you.
Great, thank you, Dawn Kepke on behalf of the California Council for Adult Education and California Adult Education Administrators Association.
Appreciate the opportunity to address you, Madam President, the board, Mr. Superintendent on this item.
Adult schools, as you probably well know, are part of, K-12 adult schools are a part of school districts, high school districts, and often work very closely with their districts to provide support for
The same type of students and population that we're talking about in terms of credit recovery opportunities, and they work with them as part of challenges they may face.
with, you know, four-year graduation rates, you know, and those sorts of things.
Our K-12 adult school teachers have great expertise in serving these students and do a phenomenal job.
They have the flexibility to tailor the approach to ensure that those students are successful and in a reasonable amount of time.
And as you also may be well aware, many of our adult schools have worked with their school districts, high school districts, as part of the LTAP process.
We would just request that flexibility be provided so that those students served within the adult schools would also be counted towards the school districts credit rate.
Thank you.
Good morning, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing CABE and Californians Together.
And I appreciate Ms.
Ortiz-Lipkin's comments with regards to providing an opportunity for other stakeholders to provide input to the development of the methodology for the LP performance status methodology.
Because this will have an effect on our schools and districts for a long time to come.
Also, we support incorporating a 5th year into the grad rate.
It's necessary for students who require additional times to graduate such as our newcomers.
We agree with the local coalition recommendations as reflected in the letter to you.
Regarding the combined 4th and 5th year measure, but also to report in the dashboard separately performance and change for both the 4th year and the 5th year.
Thank you.
Good morning, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
I will just echo the comments made by my colleague, Ms.
Zaragoza-Diaz, especially regarding the letter from the Equity Coalition.
And I also want to say how excited we are to see the dashboard on a mobile app in English and Spanish and that it's going to be translated into other languages.
We have already began sharing it with parents in the community.
Thank you.
Good morning, Angela read on behalf of the small school districts association.
Just want to thank the board and staff staff for the work on the 5th year graduation rate.
I think that as we, as this new accountability system is rolled out, you've constantly maintain the focus on the students and this will ensure that students have the opportunity to really be prepared and ready.
to go and it will encourage LEAs to work with those students to make sure that happens.
So I think it's a really exciting time for our students, particularly those who have challenges and those in our alternate schools.
And we look forward to working with you as you do the modeling and rollout.
Thank you.
Good morning, Martha Alvarez on behalf of the Association of California School Administrators.
ACCESS is also pleased to support the staff recommendation regarding the four-year and five-year graduation combination as well as three-by-five grid for the CCI.
We commend city staff for the continued commitment to evaluate and analyze opportunities to improve the dashboard indicators.
We also are disappointed about the ELPI decision by the federal government.
But nevertheless, we are excited to support the work that's happening here at the state level.
We'll be doing a webinar with CDE and state board staff on August 2nd to help administrators better understand the connection between the dashboard data and what happens in the classroom so we can improve instruction and help kids.
So we are very pleased to continue to be a partner on this work.
And we look forward to future opportunities to collaborate.
Thank you.
Great, any additional questions or comments?
I do have a couple of questions for Cindy, if Kazanas, if you could just clarify in response to some of the comments we heard.
One of them was whether adult school graduates would be included in the five year graduation rate calculations.
We're prohibited from including adult school graduates in, according to federal guidelines, they need to have a traditional diploma.
So that was one of the audit findings from the Office of Inspector General when they came out to California.
Thank you.
Thanks for clarifying that.
And then I think you answered this before, but I want to be
clear about the specifics, the question of whether both performance and change for both fourth year and fifth year graduates would be separately shown on the dashboard was one of the questions, and I just wanted to clarify that.
So that's something I'm not sure that we've actually had a discussion about.
Something to think about.
One way that we've done that is not on the actual card that you see, the first card, but in the additional data set, you see that, for example, for our English learner population for the academic indicator, you see it disaggregated further.
So I think it's something that we have a design challenge ahead to figure this out prior to a release.
We can come back around and talk about that later.
Yeah, definitely, and bring back.
Thank you.
Those were my only questions.
Seeing no others, is there a motion?
So I'll move the CDE recommendation to approve the proposed methodology for developing the four and five year graduation rate for the graduation rate indicator and the application of the three by five colored table to the CCI.
All right, and is there a second?
Second.
Thank you.
And Felisa?
Okay, I would like us to.
I know that you mentioned coming back to have the discussion on the threshold, but I want to make sure that we put a. A timeline for that, so we could have that discussion in September.
And also, when we're collecting data for the 5 year, I want to make sure that we disaggregate by.
That would be my family amendment.
I don't know how plausible that is, so I want to check with the.
I think if we could commit to the 2019 dashboard and give us the opportunity if we need to come back in November as opposed to September, that would be something I would ask for consideration.
Maybe the 2020 dashboard.
For LTL data, yes, for 2020, I would say.
and come back November of 2019 for the threshold conversation.
But start collecting data for the 2020.
Because of the extreme change in the data set for this one year only for the long-term English learners, that would be something I would recommend.
That would be my recommendation at least.
With that amendment, that friendly amendment is plausible.
Yes, with the adjusted timeline.
Okay.
Can I get an amen?
Yeah, so my friendly amendment is have the conversation on the threshold November of 2019 and look into collecting data for LTELs for the fifth year graduation rate in 2020.
All right.
All right, so we now have a motion, a second, an amendment.
All in favor say aye.
Whoever seconded it needs to agree as well.
I'm sorry?
Whoever seconded it needs to agree to the amendment.
We had several seconds.
Okay, we'll take six.
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
All right, motion carried.
Thank you very much.
All right, we're doing well on our schedule.
I want to thank you all.
We are proceeding.
We'll now take up item two, the California Assessment of Student Performance and Progress System and the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California.
We're going to get an update on assessment program activities.
And this item is going to be presented by Michelle Center of the CDE.
And when you are ready, please begin.
Good morning.
We've had some problems hearing in the back.
And so hopefully if I speak really loud that the mics will work a little better this morning.
So, Michelle Center from the assessment division here to provide our update on our CASP and our LPAC programs.
The item that I will be presenting for you today is just an information item.
I am not asking for any action this morning.
The focus of this presentation is really going to be on enhancements to the CASP and LPAC public reporting website.
which is this PowerPoint that you see before you.
But before we get to that topic, I just want to give you a few highlights of other things that were in the board item before you.
July 15th marks the close of our state testing window this school year for our CASP program.
We successfully administered millions of online tests, and I think we want to just take a moment to acknowledge that our success in California is now a model for other states throughout the nation.
We should take credit from that.
The board should take credit, the department, as well as our schools, our district, and our educators, as well as the stakeholders that help us create the program that we have.
And so we should just take a moment.
I get calls all the time from other states asking how we are pulling this off and getting advice from us.
And so that's a good place for us to be.
We also want to acknowledge that our optional California Spanish assessment which is operational for the first time this year was administered to approximately 39,000 students.
That's more than what you see in your item.
That is higher than we anticipated we would have interest in.
So that's good news also.
We also administered our first year of our science NGSS aligned science test.
We completed our field test for the alternate science test this year.
And we are excited that we'll be bringing that alternate science test to an operational phase next year.
Another topic that I want to inform you of is concerning our CASP Smarter Balanced ELA and Mathematics student reports for this year for grades four through eight.
We did have an error with the school average that was reported on that report.
It was the historical school average did not reflect accurately the school average for that student's grade for that particular school.
All of the affected reports have been reproduced, have been posted to our portal.
So all of our districts, all of our vendors already have access to these corrected reports.
Additionally.
All of our LEAs were notified that if they had any costs associated with any printing that they decided to do locally, they were to contact the California Technical Assistance Center.
Only five districts and none of them very large have actually made that contact.
So I do believe that this really didn't have a big impact considering where our districts were in terms of reporting on the field.
But it is an error nonetheless that I wanted to make sure that we told you about.
I also wanna stress and make sure I reiterate, there was no error in any student score.
There was no error in any student achievement level that was on that report.
It was only in a historical school average.
So I just wanna reiterate that for clarity.
So now with those two highlights, I wanna go ahead and move on to the PowerPoint presentation for the enhancements that will appear on the CASP and LPAC public reporting site in the fall.
These enhancements are the beginning of our department's multi-year effort to improve its public website for reporting CASP and LPAC results.
The CDE will share those future enhancements with you in the coming years.
So this project really just should be seen as one example of the many ways that we look to constantly improve upon the products and services that we provide our stakeholders here in this state.
The public website displays
Sorry, checking on myself here.
The public website displays aggregate results for the CASP and the LPAC assessments.
This effort was made in response to stakeholder input on the current public website that we have.
And the updated website goes live when our 18-19 CASP results go live.
That is anticipated in the fall.
So you get an early view of what will be on this website.
Unfortunately, that means I have to show it to you in a PowerPoint format.
I don't actually have
a live website, or a mobile device to hook up and look very, you know, technically capable.
So let's go over some of the key enhancements.
So we'll have a single homepage that contains links to results for all of our CASP and LPAC assessments in one place, which is a good thing.
We will have aggregate test results at a glance that provide users with more immediate information about the percent of students in each achievement level.
We will have improved filters to the student group selection and a new filter for school type.
New reports that allow for easier comparison between schools, district, counties, and the states will also be available.
And brand new displays for statewide achievement gaps will also be available on our public site.
I'll describe each of these enhancements and show you some visuals for them.
So this first one is the new homepage.
Let's begin by taking a look at this page.
And you'll note that you'll see links for CASP and LPAC all together.
This is something new for us.
And it's also organized instead of by the names of the test, by the actual content names that are being assessed, which we heard loud and clear from our stakeholder groups is a preference that they have.
So you'll see on here, for example, you can select English Language Arts, Literacy and Mathematics, or you can select Alternate English Language Arts, Literacy and Mathematics, Science, Alternate Science.
English language proficiency, and Spanish reading language arts.
I do want to take a moment while I'm on this slide to clarify a misconception potentially about our new CAST science test.
We will have public displays of that data, while it will not be available in fall with our Smarter Balanced results because we are still in the process of establishing those cut scores.
When it does go live, it will be on the regular site right here
along with the other assessment results.
So this new page emphasizes that we value all of our assessments and the information they can provide.
And it doesn't treat any of our assessments as more important than others.
Like you may have gotten that impression on our former site.
You may have thought Smarter Bounce was more important than any of the others.
And so this gives equal play to our other tasks.
So now let's dive a little bit deeper into the new site.
When you select the tile for English Language Arts, Literacy, and Math outlined on the left side of the screen, you'll be directed to what is called the test results at a glance page.
Based on feedback that we heard from users, they wanted to get to results with fewer clicks, if you will.
So this accomplishes that.
The new display relies on achievement level reporting, which is necessary if you want to communicate about performance across our grade spans.
From the results at a glance page, users have the ability to display data from a specific entity, for example, a school or a district, by typing in that name in the search bar.
And what we'll do now is on the next few slides, we'll look at different parts of the same results at a glance page that we are developing.
The first one is this new filtering that we will have, the streamlined filtering.
Users will now be able to select results by school type.
The school type filter will allow users to view results based on three different options.
One is all schools option.
which continues our previous practice of aggregating non-charter schools and locally funded charter schools under their school district or LEA.
For the purpose of this filter, direct funded charters are considered their own LEA.
So this is pretty much how we have been doing it.
There will now be an additional filter for charter schools, school type.
This option provides aggregations and reports based only on results from charter schools.
Both direct and locally funded charters will aggregate
within the LEA that authorized them.
The third option is the non-charter school.
That allows users to view aggregations for non-charters altogether.
It's important to note that the school type dropdown is only going to be applicable for 2018-19 and on.
We are not going back and doing this retroactively.
And it is similar to the recent DataQuest reporting enhancements that you may have noticed.
So we also made enhancements to the student group filter.
Enhancements to the student group filter include the ability for users to select an individual grade level and an individual category within a student group.
In the past, results for categories of a student group were generated in all displays.
So now you can
review results at a glance for a specific category.
So for example, what you're seeing here, instead of saying just disability status and seeing results for students with disabilities, results with students without disabilities and so forth, you would now, if you wanted to, could filter that down to just looking at students with disabilities.
An additional enhancement is the quick search feature, which allows you to search for an entity by typing in the name right there in that top right that you see there.
From the results at a glance, users view the detailed test results button, and they get to see the overall result sample that you see here, which we're lovingly calling our donut charts.
So these are our detailed test results.
It's one view of that page.
Please do not try and make any sense of any numbers on any of these slides.
These are not upcoming results that are secretly hidden in the slides.
Here's a sample of the detailed test results page.
It's very similar to last year, but it's updated so that our colors mimic the colors students and parents receive on their student score report to help facilitate understanding of those results.
Here is our detailed page, which is also very similar to what you saw last year.
I have circled in red here.
This is where you would find the average scale score for students by grade that you'll see here on this site.
I will also be talking about a new data display here in a minute that looks at achievement gaps, and it is taking information from what you see circled right there.
Just like in prior years, you also have information here about results at the various achievement levels, as well as results for claim or area information, which is not new.
So to the right of the donut grass, which you saw earlier, there's also new functionality so that
you can easily compare results.
In the past, you had to do a lot of clicking, a lot of back and forth if you wanted to compare maybe a school with a district or different schools within a district.
There was a lot of back and forth going on.
Now, with this new report, you can go ahead and add in a comparison group to what you're already looking at.
So if you wanna compare a school with the state, you have a much easier way of doing that in the future.
And now, here's our prototype.
New this year, we will be providing state-level achievement gap reports that make it easier to monitor progress on closing the gap over time.
For this year, for our first year, and they're taking it a little slow, the gap retorts will have a multi-year comparison like you see in the sample here.
The sample here is our Smarter Balanced scale range because we are starting with
Smarter Balanced in terms of our fall release.
We will have a total of 28 gap charts for Smarter Balanced this year.
That includes seven grade levels times four comparisons.
In addition, we'll have a gap chart for the California Science Test, but that will not be displayed until those results are released publicly.
So, this is the 1st time we have displayed this on our public site.
Many of you may be familiar with similar reports like this that we used to do in our press releases.
9 years ago, I'd say when we had closing the achievement gap as a goal across our entire department and so.
I thank Superintendent Thurman for making that a goal again for this department and allowing us to present this in a very visual way.
We know that this will definitely shine a light on inequities.
And it will draw attention to work that we all need to do to overcome those challenges.
And so it'll be front and center, but just do you want to point out that this is data that's already on the site.
So if the gap report that you are personally interested isn't there, this is data that we are pulling from kind of that red circle that I had on the prior chart that did show average scores.
Data's all there, but now we're doing it in a way that really highlights how you can look at it.
This is a data display similar to how NAEP produces data displays for looking at achievement gaps using the same kind of approach that you see us doing here.
So throughout this year, results from several other assessments will also be added to the public results page, including our English Language Proficiency Assessment, the California Science Test, as I mentioned, and the California Spanish Assessment.
Please keep in mind that the results displayed on the public site, of course, are always group-level results and are not individual student results.
And also do remember that our individual student results are provided to our educators via a secure website that they can access.
It's important to note that the field is encouraged to use the data they have access to via these secure systems.
They are not expected or and they are not encouraged to wait until this public release to actually use data.
Recently, Deputy Superintendent Tom Adams sent a letter to superintendents that indicated such encouragement, similar to the same thing that we did last year, wanting to make sure that our districts knew that they could use this data as part of their LCAP process.
for example, in any public meetings they may be having, and there is no need for them to wait until we do our public release.
Please note that while dates have not been established for the public release at this time, we do anticipate it will be in the fall, the first one in the fall.
And the department will provide this board with memos or an item, depending on the timing, with summary results so that you have that as part of your public meeting or public memo.
So this does conclude the update that I have, and so I'm happy to answer any questions.
Terrific.
I want to first ask Ting, one of our assessment liaisons, to provide any initial comments for us on this.
Not much other than just congratulations, Michelle, to you and your team for such an excellent job administration-wise.
I know from my school, we see every year improvements, and things go smoother and smoother every year, so thank you.
And I just want to say hooray, hooray for the GAP reports and the scale scores.
Very exciting.
Good morning again.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing CABE and Californians Together.
First, I'd like to thank CDE staff, especially Ms.
Senter and her staff and the board on the progress being made regarding the CSA and the resources made available in other languages such as the video, What is the CSA?
We're very pleased about the enhancements that were just described by Ms.
Senter.
with regards to the LPAC, and I will be sharing these with our members after this meeting.
The department and ETA should be commended in terms of the transparency and input that they have obtained from various stakeholders on the various stages of the development of the CSA.
We look forward to participating in the August CSA standards meeting, and we stand ready to assist in those efforts.
Thank you.
Good morning, Jessica Sacco with the California Stem Network, a project of Children Now.
I appreciate very much all of the work that the department has engaged in to really enhance and improve their presentation of the assessment data for the CASP system.
I think that it is going a long way in the right direction.
I would encourage, as the department continues to evaluate the effectiveness of this presentation, recognizing that this is a new one, and knowing that things evolve as we push something out, we want to reflect on whether or not that was the right approach, to consider whether or not it continues to make sense to combine together the presentation of language arts with mathematics.
and then have all other assessments as sort of other.
So what does that communicate when you put those two together, but then separate all other assessments, whether or not it would make more sense to have a language arts, a mathematics, or if we're going to be chunking content together separately from alternative assessments, or whether or not we should be communicating that in that way.
Thank you.
Thank you and I think that's the end of public comments so Michelle if you could rejoin us and we can see if there are any comments you'd like to make in response to those questions and then Felisa you're up next.
Go ahead.
Did you want to respond to that question that came from the public comment?
Sure.
I appreciate Jessica's comment.
It is a little more difficult than you would imagine to separate ELA and MAF, but like I said, it is a multi-year project, so we're happy to take that back and investigate that.
I think it is a good point.
Well, congratulations on administering the assessments.
I know my son took the Spanish assessment
I don't think, it must be rigorous, because he thought he was taking the SBAC in Spanish.
I'm like, I think the SBAC's done, and so I didn't realize that he was taking the Spanish assessment, but it must be a rigorous one.
I want to go back to one of the slides, the achievement gap reports, and I have to say that I love this as a visual.
I think that if we had data collection in the 1950s post-integration, we would have seen the achievement gap, and we've called it achievement gap, opportunity gap,
Uh, there's been a number of ways that we've now.
Termed this disparity, but what I'm interested in knowing is when we submitted the estate plan.
In the way in the back, there was an appendix and if anyone saw it, it had targets.
I don't know.
A lot of people side.
So we had these targets of what we were aiming to achieve in order to close or narrow these gaps.
And so I'm wondering how were you seeing that?
As we're looking, so reporting the data is amazing, but what do we do with it now?
Because.
Again, this achievement gap, we've known about it, we've seen it, it's persistent.
I think all efforts have tried to minimize it, but I don't know that we've narrowed it.
And so, no, we haven't narrowed it.
And so, what are we going to do then with this data to then make it actionable and to say, this is where we're at, this is where we want to be per our
Targets that we said long term target and so what happens if we don't get there?
How are we going to get there?
There's some students subgroups that are perhaps lagging further behind than others.
And again, there's so many ways to digest because if we were to look at the Asian.
the Asian subgroup and you look at Southeast Asians, which we don't collect data for, Cambodian students, Lao, Haitian, Samoan, those are Pacific Islanders.
There's just so many different ways to look at this achievement gap that's ever growing and ever evolving.
So I'm just concerned about then what?
Patricia, is there anyone else who wants to be in the queue?
Go ahead.
Well, I also want to thank you for the work that you've done to put this information together, especially information concerning the achievement gap data.
I also agree.
I went back and knowing that this was going to be prepared, I actually went back and read through the appendix and looked at that data as presented.
And the question I was hoping I would hear today, or at least the answer I was hoping I would hear today, is how does this inform, how is this data going to be used to inform
the type of intervention activities that are going on in our system of support, and is there any responsibility for the entities who are charged to do the work with our LEAs in the system of support to address or use this data to look at and understand those gaps.
Also, I'm not sure if I heard and understood clearly
if this information is available at, is this only statewide information or is it available at the LEA or school site level so that schools as part of their ongoing work in doing their needs assessment have this type of gap analysis available to them as well?
So for this first year, this first year it's only statewide.
The plan is to roll this out at the other entities on the public website in the coming years.
But we wanted to make sure this was the, this particular display that we are showing is the right display that there is an understanding before we invest in recoding of the website.
So we're looking at that.
We're also looking at the different groups.
That would want to be included in that achievement gap report And there's things that you don't necessarily Think of once we start having these conversations with districts there was a one conversation would be an example with a district we were having where Their reference group is not the reference group that we that is traditionally the reference group.
They actually use a different reference group
They use the highest achieving subgroup, whoever that may be.
In some cases, that might be, for example, the Asian subgroup.
And so they're using that as a reference group.
That's not a typical gap display.
So we also need to take a step back and really look at, how can we do this in a way that's going to meet their needs?
And so I think taking it from the slow perspective of starting out with the state and starting out with a few displays, we're able to do that and have those conversations.
I can name for you, if you're interested, the four groups that we will be including in the first year.
Yes.
That was going to be my next question.
OK.
Hispanic versus white, not Hispanic.
African-American versus white.
Students with disabilities compared to students that do not have a reported disability.
And then English learners compared to non-English learners.
So those are the four groups that we're starting with to start that conversation.
I completely recognize that there are other
comparisons that we do need to include and so we need to have those conversations with our local districts.
And you're right, this is just the start of those conversations.
I think that recently we had our reorganization within the department and we've started those conversations specifically regarding things like
the system of support, how might we use this data?
How might we make sure that assessments and the resources that we have available via our system are included in those conversations about tier one supports?
So all those conversations are really starting and we are engaging in those.
And I think that also by having our newly appointed director of our improvement and accountability division, we're really able to start engaging in something that
that maybe we hadn't gotten to yet.
Okay.
So, thank you for reading my mind and identifying the groups that you're going to be doing this gap analysis for.
One of the conversations that I continue being involved with and continue hearing is from representatives in the Asian community that looking at the Asian student subgroup as a monolith and in identifying that among those language groups, there are significant differences in performance for those students.
At some point down the road, even though it's not a requirement,
for federal reporting issues, it becomes a concern in a state like California with so many different language groups that we take another look at how we're reporting the performance of Asian students.
So when we finish with this report on Hispanic African American students with disabilities,
and the comparison on English learners.
As you're continuing your work, is there a way to take a look at how to disaggregate information?
Not now, but at some point down the road as you continue looking at this work, is there a way to take a look at the Asian student subgroup and figure out how to disaggregate that report as well?
And I recognize
At the school side level, some of those students will disappear because that's not a large enough numeric number for the report to actually show those students.
But at some level, there should be a way for us to think about how to disaggregate and collect data.
About each of those language groups or ethnic groups in that Asian subgroup so that we actually show and can understand the performance of those students.
Because I hear from my colleagues.
I hear from teachers.
I hear from parents all the time.
that as a monolith all of those students are not performing well even though that might be in that school district the highest performing student subgroup and we may be missing an opportunity to look at the needs for those students as well.
I think that Superintendent Thurmond wanted to offer some clarification when Felicia raised this question earlier so I want to turn to you.
Thank you Madam President.
Just to add on to some of the things that Ms.
Senter shared, the agency has made closing the gap an across the agency priority, which I really appreciate.
We also want to be very intentional on how we speak to some of the things that board member Ortiz-Licn and board members Ruckers have raised.
And so here's what we're doing.
We're in the early stages.
You know we've named the Closing the Achievement Gap work group that is about to make its report out of some strategies.
The first thing that they've identified is the need to build a pipeline or to expand the pipeline of educators of color who work in the elementary school grades.
And we've engaged with some foundations that are interested in how we expand that pipeline.
And to your point, Board Member Rucker, the conversation has been how do we get more
African-American, Latino, and API male educators in the classroom, because we've experienced that as well, that we don't ever want to, well, we want to make sure that we support students in all categories, but as someone who's worked with a number of students in Oakland and Richmond, many of our African-American students and API students experience some of the same conditions.
So they're living in the same communities and they're experiencing poverty and other barriers that get in the way of their success.
I've also asked four of the leading advocates around Closing the Gap to help us sort of chair our work around Closing the Gap.
And these are individuals who are recognized for their work around supporting African American students, supporting Latino students, supporting API students.
And we've asked them to help us really focus our efforts on how we can help our LEAs do a better job around their Closing the Gap work.
And finally, I want to share with you while we hold it as a badge of honor that every single department and division at the agency sees closing the gap as their priority work, we've decided that for us to be more intentional, we need to build some capacity to do even more.
And I want to share with you that we intend to build an equity office at the Department of Education.
And I've asked our Deputy Superintendent Kai Jackson to head up that effort to help us build an equity office and then to help us rebuild an office that used to exist at CDE that no longer exists.
And that is a STEAM office.
I believe that STEAM is one of the many ways that we may support our students in closing the gap.
As you said,
As you said, board member, we've known about the achievement gap for many, many years.
And so we're coming at it in lots of different ways.
And we're, we're looking at lots of ways to support it, closing the gap, including.
How do we work with foundations to help us expand dual language immersion programs?
And I want to thank you for the invitation to Patrick Henry was a very eye opening.
All the staff here, all the deputies got text messages while I was at the program saying, we're going to do more expand dual language immersion programs.
And so we are taking the comments that you all are raising to heart and trying to build our own internal capacity to be more supportive to LEAs to change the narrative that we've been hearing.
I want to thank you for that, and I appreciate knowing that work.
One request I would also like to ask both our president and you to consider is to revisit the African American Advisory Committee.
That committee had been established by this board at one point in time, and we now have data from this dashboard that shows African American students are the highest performing students, but for the wrong reasons, according to the dashboard.
And I think that the work that was initiated by that advisory committee really gave advice and helped inform some very deliberate decisions the board was tasked to make to address the achievement gap issues for African American students.
So I would also ask you to consider re-implementing the African American Advisory Committee as well.
Anyone else waiting to get in the queue?
Thank you, Superintendent Thurmond, for filling in, and congratulations.
As we all know, that's work that's incredibly important and needs to continue at the state level.
What I wanted to explore was what data is available at the local level, because I think I heard Michelle say this a couple of times, and I just wanna make sure that folks are aware that those scale scores are available to the LEAs by subgroup, as I recall.
And remember that our LCAP and all of the work around it talks about goals being set at the local level by subgroup.
So I just want to call that out and make sure that people understand that's out there.
And also too, because I have a couple of my friends in the audience that are county superintendents and they are our partners in working with those LEAs that need support by subgroup.
that that information is available.
And my guess is it's not all that hard to get at and to create reports locally to say, hey, so that while we're working on this, and this is gonna be very important work at the state level going forward, it's available now, locally, and it should be addressed locally, rigorously, every single year.
Correct, the data is available locally, it's also available
on our website for public viewing of those various subgroups.
I think what the sample does is it does provide a template and a model for those interested in how might you do a visual display of the gap that is appropriate use of our data.
This provides that template and model to do so while we're at the same time investigating ways to expand.
I also just wanted to echo the appreciation for the focus on closing the achievement gap and making sure that the data is not something that advocacy groups or parents have to actually search and rescue, but is very apparent and obvious and also is readily available to all.
The question that I had actually is about the local implementation in my own hometown of Los Angeles.
Some of the best achievement gap closing work is happening in magnet schools, and oftentimes one of the pieces of feedback that we hear from parents is that data is disaggregated or available to be pulled more manually currently at the school site level, but you can't actually disaggregate between multiple
schools hosted on the same school site.
So if there are three magnets within one school site, you can't actually figure out where are they actually doing well for African-Americans to graduate.
And wondering if that is something that is anticipated down the line as well.
Maybe we should have a conversation after to make sure that they have all of their roles established as they need to.
Our district level access would provide access to various schools within the district, and so we should have a conversation about how we can make sure that they are set up appropriately to do the work that they need to do.
But that means that the district has access but not parents.
Districts have the authority to establish roles and permissions within the system.
So it's a local control decision rather than one with the state.
All right.
Any other comments or discussion, questions?
Thank you for this really informative report, Michelle.
We appreciate it.
And I'm just going to encourage people to take an individual break as they may need it.
And we're going to move right on ahead into agenda item three, which is the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California, Finding of Emergency and Proposed Emergency Regulations for Amendments to the California Code of Regulations.
And the item will be presented by Michelle Center.
So thank you for hanging in there with us.
Please feel free to begin.
Okay, so the item before you today, item three, does require action on the part of the board.
The recommendation for the LPAC regulations is that you approve the finding of emergency, adopt the proposed emergency regulations, direct the CDE to circulate the required notice of proposed emergency action, and then submit the emergency regulations to the Office of Administrative Law for approval.
authorizes CDE to take any necessary action to respond to any direction or concern expressed by the OAL during its review of the finding of emergency and proposed emergency regulations.
So that is the action before you.
The approval of these proposed emergency regulations will more closely align test registration and administrative procedures between the LPAC and the CASP and will increase the breadth of accessibility resources
for this year's LPAC administration.
I'll provide you with a summary of the significant proposed changes to the LPAC regulations.
Proposed revisions and additions to the definitions in the regulations have three purposes.
The first reason is to integrate common terms that are relevant to computer-based platforms.
For example, assessment management system is one term that we now define within our regulations.
The second reason was to make revisions that increased continuity in the terms used across our multiple assessment programs to make life easier for those administering those systems.
For example, we now have a common definition for pupils with the most significant cognitive disabilities, a common term and definition for test administration manual, those types of things.
Also, the LPAC and CAST programs have gone to electronic agreements for test security agreements and affidavits.
So proposed revisions are made as appropriate throughout the regulations to reflect this procedural change.
And third, definitions regarding accessibility resources are included.
Two that I wanna highlight for you today, given prior conversations with the board.
One is the Technology Navigation Assistant and the other is the Designated Interface Assistant.
Each of these roles are to assist students with navigating within the test delivery system so that technology is not a barrier for accessing the test, but there is a difference in the level of support between those two different accessibility supports that I mentioned.
The first is a universal tool.
The role of the technology navigation assistant would be available to all students who may have a technology, may not be familiar with technology so that they may correctly navigate the test delivery system.
So for example, they may help them operate the mouse, provide a scroll bar assistance, demonstrate how to expand or collapse the windows and those types of things.
That's one.
The next is the Designated Interface Assistant.
That's a different layer of support available to all students that have an identified need.
So during a one-on-one administration.
So the first one could be done in terms of helping students within a group administration.
It's not as much support, but it's available to all students and can be done on the spot.
The second is a higher level of support, the Designated Interface Assistant.
which would then require a one-on-one test administration for students who need that help.
The designated support is intended to assist the student with input of responses into the test delivery system.
So, for example, in the writing domain, the student would then be unable to provide their written responses on the keyboard, for example.
The student could provide them in writing, and then the designated interface assistant would then input that
into the test delivery system for them so that the system is not a barrier to students.
The majority of proposed changes to the regulations involve enhancements to those types of accessibility supports for LPAC.
So attachment one of your June LPAC memo did include an accessibility framework.
That framework did inform the proposed revisions that you see before you, and that framework was developed by ETS, but they solicited input from many, including select members of our LPAC technical advisory group, including Martha Thurlow.
We also received input from the following stakeholder groups.
The California Association of Bilingual Educators,
the California County Superintendent's Educational Services Administration Association, California Federation of Teachers, California Parent Teachers Association, California School Boards Association, California School for the Blind, California School for the Deaf, California Science Teachers Association,
California Teachers Association, Californians Together, and the Special Education Local Plan Area Administrators of California.
So all of those groups were provided an opportunity to review and provide input on the framework, which we then used as the basis of those regulations.
We considered and in fact made changes based on some input we received.
So the Advisory Commission on Special Education was also briefed on these new accessibility resources, and they were supportive of the recommendations that you see before you.
As a paper-based assessment, the LPAC had non-embedded accessibility resources only.
Non-embedded resources are those which are provided by an LEA outside of an online test delivery system.
The transition to a computer-based assessment has allowed the LPAC program to leverage the embedded resources available in the online
delivery system.
You may have noticed in the regulations that there are three tiers of support, again, very similar to our other in terms of using the same terminology.
And we're very pleased that we are able to provide this expanded list of accessibility resources for our English learners throughout the state.
Finally, proposed changes to the LPAC regulations create electronic efficiencies for LEAs,
In these proposed regulations, LEAs are no longer required to keep paper copies of the test security agreement and the test security affidavit.
These forms are managed electronically, creating efficiencies that our LEAs are very appreciative of.
In summary, the topics that require your approval include approve the finding of emergency and adopt the proposed emergency regulation amendments,
Emergency regulations are needed to ensure that these proposed changes are in place in time for the 19-20 test administration.
Also, CDE is requesting approval from the board to circulate the required notice of proposed emergency action and then submit the emergency regulations to OAL for approval.
Lastly, CDE is requesting authorization to take any necessary action to respond to any direction or concern expressed by the OAL during the review of the finding of emergency and the proposed regulations.
So, I'm happy to answer any questions that you have.
So, in our assessment laser, if she has any comments about this item.
No, no comments.
I do appreciate that we are, well, I'm making a comment.
I'm sorry.
I do appreciate that we are aligning the vocabulary across the board on all this.
And then I just want to say that we, there will be opportunities for additional stakeholder input as we have action to approve the regular regulations.
And then that would also set a process for more input.
There any quick clarifying questions from board members before we go to public comment?
I'll take those.
I do have one because this item used to come to me, but I wasn't included this time.
And so I'm looking at the definition of translator, and we cite a section here.
And so we talk about these are the requirements to be a translator, an employee of an LEA, an employee of an NPS, a person supervised.
But in that, those three criteria points, there's nothing about being proficient in the student's native language.
And so how do we ensure that the translator is actually proficient in the academic language of the student?
So you are correct that there is not a requirement, for example, that they be a certificated translator.
That isn't a requirement.
It is the
the same definition of a translator that we are using for our other tests.
And I haven't heard that there is a concern that those that are doing those translation services are not proficient.
I believe those are the individuals that the students are using on a regular basis as part of their classroom experience.
Have we ever had an instance, and I could envision this, where we don't have a translator based on the student's primary language?
And how would we resolve that?
That is a local requirement to ensure that they have a translator if it is needed for the student.
I have no knowledge of ever being contacted by a school or district indicating that they have been unable to find a translator.
I'm making assumptions that those of you who are at school sites might be more familiar, but I'm assuming that they have avenues for reaching out to others, maybe county offices of education, for example, to help provide those kind of translation services.
Let me get to public comment.
I'm sorry.
Did I miss something?
about whether the translators are always available.
Let's get to public comment and then we'll have a broader discussion.
Oh, there is none.
Okay, so we can have any broader discussion we'd like to have about this.
Anyone else want to be in the queue?
So, Michelle, first of all, I know that this is connected to a separate item that's coming at the end of the agenda.
I appreciate the emergency regulations for the purposes you've outlined that it creates and gives some guidance for districts for the work that they need to do and creates the flexibility they need to have.
But at this end of the dais, we are sitting here commenting on the fact what it does not do is improve the resources of the accessibility
that districts will need to make sure that these translators are available or that some of the local issues concerning support for the administration of this work is actually done.
But I do believe it is important to get these regulations out and that there is a clear emergency and that it's important for this item to go forward.
And just as a response to that, it just so happens that we are having a focus group with
principles with site principles this week or next week.
Time is running.
But I'm happy to go ahead and start having those conversations about whether or not that is a problem that they are experiencing locally.
And we can go ahead and add that to those focus group conversations that we're having.
I appreciate that.
In my own career as a classroom teacher, I had Hmong, Laotian, Vietnamese, and even Russian students in my classroom.
And while there were translators available for Hispanic students, for those students, there were never translators available.
And so I do know for a fact that there are difficulties with creating and making sure that those resources are there, just from my own professional experience.
And I highly doubt
that that has significantly improved since the time I left the classroom.
Thank you.
Hema?
Can we also have a focus group with students?
Because sometimes in the organizing, what we do with students, especially newcomers, a lot of students voice things that sometimes the principals don't see, or sometimes principals choose to ignore.
Not assuming those principals are ignoring, but just talking to students who have issues, such as students who speak Arabic, students who speak Hmong,
an indigenous language from Guatemala and just other languages that people don't commonly use it's really hard to find translators for because students have a different experience because sometimes especially when having newcomer programs what's the struggle is that there's students from multiple different countries in the room and so to get translators especially in places like Oakland where we have newcomers constantly coming in there is a shortage of translators and you know students have a unique perspective on how that impacts them and how
definitions could really change the experience.
Any other comment?
I think we're ready for a motion.
Do you want to put the motion up or is that?
The motion.
Or we can simply move to accept the board's, the CDE recommendation.
Do I have a motion?
Thank you.
CDE's recommendation.
I'll second.
Okay.
One member to sign.
Anybody else have any comments or questions?
All right.
All in favor say aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
Motion passes.
Thank you very much.
And we really need to get through before lunch.
So we're doing well.
And this is really the item on the state seal of civic engagement item for the recommended criteria.
And we're here to really talk about initial review and feedback.
This item will be presented by Barbara Murchison of CDE.
Hi, Barbara.
Good morning.
Please begin.
Morning, President Darling-Hammond, Superintendent Thurman, board members.
I'm Barbara Murchison from the Educator Excellence and Equity Division here at the CDE, and this morning I'll be talking to you about... You can attend to our speaker.
Thank you.
Present you information regarding the state seal of civic engagement, as well as the draft criteria
for the seal for your consideration.
I'm going to share first some information about the authorizing statute, and then I'll share the process through which the criteria were developed.
And then I will share the proposed criteria with you.
Again, this is primarily an information item.
The CDE recommends that the board provide feedback on the recommended criteria today, and then we'll make whatever changes you suggest and bring them back to you for approval at a later date.
All right.
Got it.
Thank you.
All right, so the State Seal of Civic Engagement was authorized with the signing of Assembly Bill 24 in 2017.
Notably, this bill passed unanimously in both chambers and was signed by Governor Brown in October of 2017.
The intent of the seal is to encourage students in California schools to become civically engaged in democratic governmental institutions at local, state, and national levels.
California education code requires the superintendent of public instruction to develop and to recommend the state board criteria for awarding the state seal of civic engagement and students receiving the seal must demonstrate excellence in civics education and participation and have an understanding of the United States and California constitutions and democratic systems of government.
The statute requires the superintendent to incorporate the six proven practices for effective civic learning developed by the Education Commission of the States and any and all other best practices for civic learning and engagement.
Briefly, those practices include instruction in government, history, geography, law, democracy, and economics.
That's number one.
Discussion of current events and controversial issues, service learning experiences,
extracurricular activities, student participation in school governance, and simulations of the democratic process.
The superintendent was also required by the statute to consult with a group of classroom teachers who teach history, social science, and secondary schools in developing the seal.
The superintendent was also required
to consider including a variety of other criteria, including completion of history, government, and civics courses, and participation in community service or extracurricular activities.
The statute provides some flexibility for the superintendent to develop other requirements as deemed appropriate.
The statute's intent is that the criteria provide all students with the opportunity to earn the seal.
The seal should recognize outstanding achievement, but be something not necessarily tied to grades or other established measures of achievement.
The seal should also provide benefit to students beyond high school.
So those were the statutory requirements.
Now I'll shift a little bit to the process by which the draft criteria before you today were developed.
The CDE conducted an application process to identify classroom teachers to serve on the SEAL advisory group.
The group represented history, social science teachers from across the state with the greatest representation in Southern California.
In November, we hosted a video conference with this group in collaboration with our county office partners.
in Los Angeles, Ventura, and Sacramento counties.
We walked the advisory group through a set of prompts based on the statute to solicit feedback about what should be included in the criteria.
Again, the intent is that the criteria are actually grounded by practitioners knowing what is and isn't doable in high schools.
We then conducted a public comment period around these draft criteria.
Most of the comments we received were around making sure the seal was accessible to all students, not just those with good grades in history social science.
We also heard that civics education should be the purview of teachers beyond the history social science classroom and that the state should encourage local civic action through the seal.
Early on, we also met with members of the Advisory Commission on Special Education to seek their advice around ensuring that the SEAL is accessible to students with disabilities.
And we also convened CDE staff from across the department to review the draft criteria.
These were staff who serve English learners, migrant students, students in special education programs, foster youth, and youth who are homeless, to just make sure that the criteria
didn't preclude any of those students or students in those groups from earning the seal.
Finally, we convened representatives from the Power of Democracy group.
So my colleague, Janet Mann, is sitting behind us.
She is kind of the civics champion in our division, and civics is her thing.
And she has been helping me to understand how many folks are really deeply engaged in the civics work.
So I'm going to get to this paragraph, and I'm like,
Just the other day, I was like, wow, that person's from where?
So there's a long list of folks who were engaged in building this.
The Power of Democracy Group, the California History Social Science Project, the Constitutional Rights Foundation, the Promoting Authentic College Career and Civic Readiness Assessment Systems Committee, the Los Angeles County Office of Education, and the California Civic Engagement Project all were convened to help us talk through that draft after it had gone through a variety of other reviews.
So, this seems like a good time to thank all of the people who are deeply civically engaged in helping us to develop and refine the recommended criteria you have before you today.
So, let's take a look at the recommended criteria.
There are 5 of them as shown on this slide.
In general, students must be in good academic standing and on track to satisfy requirements to earn a high school diploma.
They must demonstrate an understanding of United States and California constitutions, local governments, tribal government structures and organizations, and democratic principles, concepts, and processes.
They must participate in a civic engagement project to address real problems.
They must present a written or oral reflection of the project activities.
And they must exhibit character traits that support civic mindedness and have a letter of recommendation from someone outside their family that attests to that.
So I want to be very clear that this is an absolutely voluntary program.
Districts that choose to award students the SEAL have broad flexibility in determining their own local requirements based on these criteria.
The recommended criteria and guidance is designed to assist schools and districts to develop their own local policy around their own requirements for students to earn the SEAL.
And very early on, one of the early conversations we met with one of the groups who are very passionate about civics, and they brought several profiles of students who they thought would be eligible for the SEAL.
And it turns out that two of them
were kind of composite students.
They said, oh, they have this attribute, and they've done this thing, and they've worked on this project.
And then the third one was a student in Oakland, Unified School District, and had done all these amazing things and was very civically engaged in her school community.
And I think that was in like July or August of last year we had that meeting, and we looked at these composite students, one who was not a composite.
And then in September, I came to present something to the board.
And remember, Cardenas was sitting there.
She was the non-composite student.
I was like, OK, so that's a really high bar.
We certainly want to.
I'm like, she looks really familiar.
I'm like, oh, she is our seal of civic engagement.
So I'm glad you're here today.
I was like, certainly, we want you to earn the seal.
And students like you to earn the seal.
But we also want to make sure the seal is accessible to students who may not be quite as accomplished as serving on the State Board of Education.
It's a thought.
We'll talk afterward.
So again, we want there to be standards.
What we're building, what we've been tasked to build is criteria and then to provide guidance that helps local education agencies shape that criteria and create local board policy of their own based on their local conditions.
So criteria one requires that students be in good academic standing and on track to satisfy requirements to earn a high school diploma.
LEAs can define good standing in a number of ways and adapt the definition to meet the needs of their students.
The phrase good standing is intentionally used so that the criteria works within their own district graduation requirements.
The language in the implementation guidance again throughout
is meant to be inclusive and assumes that districts will tailor their local board policy with the input of district stakeholders around what students need to do to earn the seal.
As I mentioned, CDE staff from divisions representing various student groups met to provide feedback on one of the early drafts to make sure that the criteria was accessible to all students.
This first bullet point being on track to graduate
Using district or state requirement was specifically added to ensure that students who are unable to meet district requirements to graduate could qualify for the seal by meeting state minimum requirements.
The 2nd bullet demonstrating academic improvement for all youth.
including challenges faced by students who are English learners, homeless, in foster care, or incarcerated should be considered, was added to suggest to LEAs that students who show academic improvement should be eligible for the SEAL.
The overall grade point average should not disqualify a student from being able to earn the SEAL.
And again, it was very important that students with disabilities are able to access the SEAL.
Those that we spoke to around this, including a subcommittee of the Advisory Commission on Special Education, suggested that how well a student is doing in relation to their individualized education program might also serve as a measure of good standing.
But again, these are considerations that we'd like LEAs to think about.
Criteria two requires that students demonstrate a competent understanding of the United States and California constitutions and know how local governments and tribal governments work, and also understand democratic principles, concepts, and processes.
Again, LEAs have great latitude around the phrase competent understanding.
LEAs can determine a passing grade for U.S.
history and American government, or they might include a benchmark or civic assessment, or they might consider student participation in governmental meetings.
LEAs could also encourage, and we think one of the criteria in the statute was that this would be of benefit to folks beyond high school.
We also thought it was important to include in the guidance that LEAs encourage grade 11 student fulfillment of the criteria so that they could affix the seal to a transcript or to use in their college applications.
Criteria three, students must participate in an informed civic engagement project to address real world problems.
In the guidance, we encourage educators to start with the six proven practices of effective civic learning.
This document can help educators support students as they build civic skills during class and around the school campus as a whole.
And it also includes a number of resources that provide information on various civic engagement activities.
The fourth criterion requires that students present a written or oral reflection of student civic engagement project activities.
The self-reflection should include the project's impact on the student's learning and growth in civic skills.
This could include working with others, the effectiveness of the action taken for the community the student endeavored to serve, and ideas for future or further work.
And finally, students must exhibit character traits that support civic-mindedness, supported by a letter of recommendation from a peer, educator, mentor, local elected official, or a non-familial community member.
There are a few examples of what is meant by civic-mindedness on this slide.
I will not read them all to you, but additional information on civic values,
may be found in the Revitalizing K-12 Civic Learning in California Blueprint for Action document, which is available on the CBE State Seal webpage.
So the document ends with two tables that provide additional resources about student projects
that could potentially support student attainment of the SEAL, one for high school students and one for kindergarten through grade 12.
The guidance will be updated as new resources become available.
So with that, I'd like to say there are many additional efforts underway to support civics education in California and the CDE's next step once the SEAL is approved.
will be to coordinate and organize all of that information in a way that schools and districts who are supporting students throughout the grade spans see their civic education work as an on-ramp to student attainment of the SEAL.
So we have a variety of resources available now, but to make them kind of coherent and accessible, so here's some things you can think about in elementary school, here's some things we can think about in middle, and leading up, sort of organizing of the resources and the guidance
to help LEAs see this as a path to the seal and not just something for high school students.
So much more information, including the documents I've mentioned today and information regarding the criteria development activities, is available on the CDE webpage that's here on this slide.
We have a webpage devoted to this.
I do want to take a moment to thank Janet Mann, again,
our civics person, and her manager, Aline Allison Zaria, in our division, for their hard work to get us to this point.
It's been about a year of work and convening and refining.
And I also need to provide a shout out to former Deputy Superintendent Tom Adams, who was very passionate about this work and helped shepherd it before his retirement last month.
So with that, I can take any questions you have at this time or however
All right, thank you.
First, I want to ask Kim Brownson if she wants to offer some comments as our liaison.
Yes, so thank you to the Department of Education for putting together a set of criteria and recommendations and guidance and the full sort of thoroughness and diligence with which you guys approach this work.
I think one of the things that came across in the memo that I just wanted to lift up was that part of the legislation was born out of the idea and some data showing that civics education is not equitably distributed across the state and that we know that poor and minority kids across California have fewer civics opportunities.
Um, I think what's really exciting about this, um, is also that it, to my mind, civic engagement is, is also analogous with, um, sort of teaching and muscle memory around agency, um, and around sort of improvement, um, efforts at the community level.
So I wanted to also reflect gratitude for inclusion of this not just being a sort of a seal that goes on to a high school graduate's well-deserved, when we have a composite person or an individual who embodies all of that, but the recognition that like other learned behaviors, they don't sort of spring full-blown in 12th grade or 11th grade.
These are muscle memory,
Attributes that you can build these habits very young and so the inclusion and I think it was table two of elementary and middle school.
Those don't culminate in a seal, but it is part of what I think acculturates students to the idea that they have agency and that we expect as all Californians that all kids should actually be able to affect the order of their lives.
The last thing I just wanted to
Paul, as food for thought moving forward, as there's some opportunity, I think, to think about playing up certain aspects of, I think it's criteria four and five around what sort of exemplars we hold up.
There's a
I think, implicit part of the presentation, which is about, for example, standing up for kids who are being bullied or being harassed, which I think is a lovely entry point.
But part of, I think, what civics education also is a proxy for is teaching kids that there is a notion of community that is not necessarily about looking in the mirror and only taking care of people who look exactly as you do or as I do.
or as in an era of increasing resegregation of schools.
There's been a lot of work done at the UCLA Project for Civil Rights about the degree to which California schools have resegregated and kids have less access to diversity and kids who don't come from similar economic or dissimilar economic situations.
But civics is also a place where
kids learn to think of their body politic as being diverse, heterogeneous, and valuable.
The quote that keeps coming to mind is after the terrorist attacks in New Zealand, the prime minister immediately went on television and said, we are them, they are us, this is our community.
And that's a civics frame to my mind that I think we could benefit from in California.
Yes, Matt.
So first of all today, Superintendent, your staff has been great.
They've really made some solid recommendations and it's been nice to be part of this discussion today.
I just wanted to throw that out there because it's been really exciting to see what's happening in the work and this included as well.
And my question is that I love this because you've done such a great job of giving an on-ramp to so many students and what
What strikes me is that a student with disabilities can gain access to this.
However, my question would be, in that criteria one, when we say be in good standing, we've defined good standing, and we've given the number, but when it says and on track for a graduation high school diploma, does it immediately eliminate a moderate disabled student who is on certificate track from obtaining this certificate?
And if so, is there a way to create an on-ramp?
Because they can acquire, with the flexibility, all the criteria, two, three, four, and five.
A local district could make an on-ramp for them with a parent and an IEP team, but that one, they would be able to define good standing through an IEP, but the end on track would immediately, seems like it might eliminate them.
I think we'll go back and look closely at the statute to make sure that that's not a statutory requirement, and if it isn't.
Yeah, so let's come back to that in our discussion period, because we do have some public comment.
So let's just do clarification questions now, and then we'll take our public comment, then we'll come back, because that's a really important point for us to discuss further.
Okay, Ting, and then Nikki, and we'll come back over to Hannah.
Sorry.
So, thanks, Barbara.
Great work, and I was so excited to see this on our agenda.
It's about time, right?
I know it's been a couple years in the making.
I'm on two minds about this, because on one hand, I do appreciate the broad flexibility that's given to LEAs to develop their,
benchmarks based on the criteria here, and I do believe that it provides a broader access to achieving this.
At the same time, I feel that civics learning, civics engagement is so critical and so important, and I had hoped that we would one day be able to consider this as part of our CCI.
And if that is the case, then I think we've got too much of this flexibility.
And it's basically what I've comments I've made around the Golden State seal.
Diploma as well.
It's just we're given that much and so I'd just on top in addition to this.
I'd like to maybe collect information on what types of Projects and things that are happening because I can see different leas providing different levels of rigor in accepting this and then the other is if we were to consider one day of putting this on our CCI including it in CCI and
What can we do to maybe, I don't know, standardize it or make it hit a certain criteria level?
Because I do think this is so critical, and it's just, it's the foundation of our democracy, and we need to have it, and I just think we need to highlight it.
These are great comments.
I'd like to ask us to stick to clarification right now, and then we'll come back, because we do need a robust discussion of some of these points.
Nikki?
I'll reserve my comments for the discussion, but I do have a question.
Our focus today is the criteria and reviewing the criteria, but I do want to ask, what is the plan for supporting administrators and teachers at our schools and districts in helping them actually implement this and help students along on these pathways?
for that question.
Janet can't wait.
She's sitting there.
I can't even look at her right now.
So after the SEAL is approved and we have our resources and everything is organized, we were talking yesterday about how she will go out and do a roadshow.
We'll do some communications around it.
We'll get her on every conference agenda to be sharing information about the SEAL and how to support students to attain the SEAL.
So that's part of our dissemination plan.
We talked very deliberately about how this is very important and way too important to just say, yay, we have a seal and then just put it aside.
So we plan to take it out on the road and help people to understand.
Obviously, we have a number of county offices.
A lot of the professional learning around civics right now lives with our county offices, right?
And as I mentioned, there's a lot of great work happening already with civics education and supporting
folks, and there are a lot of people probably watching this right now with gated breath, very excited for this to be happening.
So, obviously, we would leverage those systems and existing infrastructure to support people to understand and implement and advance this work.
Thank you for that question.
In addition to Janet,
And Hema, did you have a clarifying question?
So a student can qualify for the SEAL if they only did one project and they got approved, right?
It depends on what the LEA decides in their local board policy around how they are going to award the SEAL to students.
OK.
So I know there's a lot for us to talk about with respect to these guidelines, so we will come back to that.
I do want to give some opportunity for public comment, and I know we have some.
Dave Gordon.
one of the great proponents of civic education.
We should thank you, Dave, both for what you've been doing on this score and for being with us today.
Oh, thank you.
President and board members, this is just a fantastic opportunity and I really want to thank the CDE staff, Barb and Janet, who put their hearts into this as well as all of the work and working with so many groups as you heard.
I think for this, it's so important that we, our goal is to reach all young people, not some, not a few.
not this group or that group, but really all young people, because that's who we will depend upon to carry our democracy forward.
And secondly, I think in the preamble and in your criteria, the suggestion is made to begin early.
I just came this morning from one of my board members, Dr. Al Brown, runs an asthma camp
for young people, three or four days.
He takes kids away and it's all staffed by volunteers, nurses, and young people.
young people go and they travel and they learn and they get to feel the disposition of I'm helping, I'm contributing.
And I think if we can incentivize this in some way to make sure we begin at the elementary grades up through the middle grades, this shouldn't be just a high school thing.
So again,
We are so excited out in the field to help with this in any way that we can.
And thank you so much for your support of this.
And thanks to CDE.
We're really excited to get going.
Thank you.
All right.
So, we've got at least a couple really meaty issues on the table that I want to be sure we have time to discuss.
One is the question of making sure this really is accessible to all kids.
And, you know, it can be
not only students who might be on track for a certificate of attendance rather than a diploma, but it might be the thing that turns on somebody who is not yet on track for a diploma, but gets engaged in school in this way.
So I think that's a really important piece of it.
And then the other piece is, how do we frame it sufficiently so that if we wanted to have it as part of CCI,
we would feel like it had the shape and the form to allow it to do that.
It's related to Emma's comment as well about, is it just one project?
So how much local control and how much framing is the other piece of the puzzle?
the puzzle that I've heard so far.
There may be others.
So let's open up some discussion on that so that we can give Barbara some feedback.
And Barbara, please feel free to comment.
So just on that point, one of the comments I was thinking to make is that we delete from that first guideline on track for a diploma so that that is not a confusion and that we can really think about all kids who make this a part of their.
So who would like to, anybody else want to get in on the discussion of these issues that have been raised?
Yes, Patricia and then Hema, and who else on this side, anyone?
Well, I was also looking forward to this discussion today, particularly because I was also thinking about the CCI and the indicator and how this would be used.
And one of the things I would like to say, I think it's,
great to have the local flexibility.
I think that's important because we cannot create a one-size-fits-all definition of what civic engagement is because it looks different in different communities for some very particular reasons.
HEMA's leadership as a student leader in Oakland
would look very different in the district where I taught right here in Sacramento County, not because it wouldn't be supported, but because there are different reasons and different causes that students choose to get engaged as student leaders in Sacramento County than in Oakland.
But what I would like to see for each of the criteria, because we are looking at creating this as a state seal,
and we are looking at including this particular designation as part of our accountability system, I think each criteria should have at least one minimum statewide criteria that the districts must address.
Or maybe even refining and shaping the criteria to an outline.
The example I can give is when the state created retention and promotion policy mandates,
It did not say, here's what your policy must state.
It gave an outline of what the criteria the policy must address.
And so if we look at the five criteria that are listed here and say, at a minimum, the criteria must include this, that would be a way to standardize what is implemented so that we do have a measurable
metric that we can say meets a level of rigor that is uniform across the state so that it could be included in the accountability metric.
So I hope that suggestion makes sense.
Thank you so much for this.
This is very exciting to me because, you know, Dolores Huerta, an organizer from the United Farm Workers Union, always talked about how sometimes it's important to acknowledge the work organizers are doing.
And, you know, this is really helpful because there's some students out there who always wonder, like, is the work that I'm doing even being recognized?
And it's not because they want to get all the attention.
It's because sometimes little things make an impact.
And so a seal like this can really encourage young people to step forward.
But something I see that's missing is talking about how civic engagement and organizing and activism is something continuous.
And that's why I asked about the project.
Because what I'm scared is that there's something called clout that we use.
I don't know if y'all have heard the term.
So cloud is like, you know, no, not that, it's because like cloud is something more recent.
It's like something that we've been seeing in the organizers and youth organizers, like doing things for cloud.
And, you know, doing things for cloud can be very hurtful because sometimes what students may do or young people may do is that they will do one project and be like, cool, I'm going to get this seal that's going to look good for this college so I could get in.
And I'm really scared for that.
That's why I want to make sure that in this language, we make sure that it's continuous.
so that students get out of that mindset because maybe they were in the beginning, but because they kept having to do this work, they do build a passion.
And so just having some flexibility and really talking about them more and how this is framed can be very helpful because I want to make sure that students become passionate about what they're talking about and realize that anything you're passionate about can be a form of organizing.
Yes, we're saying no to clout.
I just learned the term, but you have to use it 12 times to own it.
So I think for me, I run national programs and civic engagement is core to the model that we use.
And we have a democracy project.
We have a service learning project.
It looks very different in different communities.
But we do try to anchor it in some level of rigor across the sites that we work with.
One of the things that we found in doing literature on service learning, for instance, they will cite things like Latinos have the lowest level of service learning engagement.
But that's because they're looking at service learning through a very mainstream lens that does not take into account things like being a language broker, sending money back to the home country, things of that nature that are very service oriented.
And in the same way, I fear that we may lose what civic engagement looks like.
And when working with youth, we've had a hard time.
sort of setting that civic mindset for students where they see themselves as someone who has the potential to be civically engaged.
For instance, if you're undocumented, yes, you could be civically engaged.
If your parents are undocumented, yes, they also can be civically engaged.
You could be the voice for others.
You could lift the message of others, right?
And so a lot of it has to do as board member, but T.O.
Bronson, I'm sorry.
We're at the first name level right now.
One of the things- Definite last names are in the- Well, I know.
I know.
Those husbands.
So, I want to make sure that we are considering ways that we provide some guidance so that some of these projects that may be towards a community that is vulnerable and marginalized can still be seen as an act of civic engagement.
Going back to the comment about the graduation and not including that, if we don't include that, then I don't know if we could include it in the CCI because the CCI is grounded on the now combined graduation rate.
So we have to be mindful again that everything we do, you tinker here, it has an impact over here.
So, thank you.
Other, yes, Nikki.
Just if comments on the criteria, I'm very supportive of the way they're crafted.
They're open enough to encourage creativity and local solutions, and it makes my heart sing to see the inclusion of tribal government structures and organizations.
So I'm just delighted to see that in there.
And that said, with the rollout process, back to your point, Member Ortiz-Ricn,
Civic engagement looks different at different ages and in different communities and with different structures.
So, as we're rolling this out in our communities and helping to support teachers and administrators and supporting our students and attaining the seal.
It's really important to engage community-based partners, tribal governments, because there may be a student who's civically engaged, say, in their tribal community, but maybe that looks very different than what they're doing at the school site for a variety of reasons.
I think the more connections that we can make between community-based partners and our schools will really help maximize the impact of this very important work.
I also agree with the stakeholder recommendations that this is not just in the domain of history and social science.
This is interdisciplinary.
And it really starts at the youngest ages because we're building a culture of engagement and civic mindedness and inclusive communities.
So I'm really thrilled with just all the good input and how that's reflected in this criteria here.
Thank you.
Were you wanting to I saw you adjust your microphone.
So, yeah, I'm hearing the comments.
I really appreciate all the, all the thoughtful comments that are on this topic here.
I wonder if maybe part of this and maybe helping to standardize is the having.
the comment around consistency, that this didn't just happen in their 11th grade year or their 12th grade year and they did a senior project and that's gonna count as that, that it needs to be consistent.
And so I wonder if there's a way that we can say that has met these criteria consistently for three grade levels or something along those lines so that there's some, I know, it means tracking.
It means like somebody has to collect the data.
But I know it becomes more complicated but I think we need to up the level a little bit.
Sue?
Yeah, I mean, I'm sort of mulling over what are the options for us to provide guidance to LEAs about here's sort of the minimum standard, if you will, in order for this to be included in the CCI.
But then it made me think maybe we're on the wrong track.
Maybe this is about social and emotional learning.
And we've struggled, as you know, we got so much stuff loaded at the high school end that we're overweight there.
We've talked a lot, and I appreciate people's comments.
I think it's really true that earlier you can get kids involved in being civic-minded and service-oriented and all that, the better off we're all gonna be.
So if we thought about it in a different way and said, hey, think about this as a measurement for social-emotional learning, I think, A, we might make it more inclusive.
We would get to students who, especially, I'm attuned to Matt's comment about students with moderate disabilities
But we'd also be able to be measuring these things as kids are moving along through the system rather than creating yet another high-stakes measurement of how do we get it into the CCI.
So just a thought as an option.
Question, and I know Patricia's waiting also.
In the way you're conceptualizing it, if it were not part of the CCI, would it appear somewhere or would
It would be in the social-emotional learning.
As a local indicator.
Right, as a local indicator.
And because, and I was thinking about it, because we are trying to give a lot of local flexibility, and you know, I'm kind of the local flexibility queen.
So I like that.
I like it a lot that we're trying to do it that way.
And I think the communities are so different.
Member Rucker mentioned, you know, how the differences between what might be going on in Sacramento and Oakland.
I can only imagine how different it will be in Siskiyou County.
than it is in Fresno County.
So I'm just trying to find a way, and I think the local criteria might be a way to think about it.
And again, a way to think about how we're encouraging this throughout a student's career.
Because otherwise, if we're focused on CCI, it's like, ooh, what happens when they graduate?
Does this make them college and career ready?
There's kind of a bigger purpose here, I think, in some ways.
So, just encourage us to think about that.
But yes, it would be measured to answer your question.
I think that Board Member Burr's comment does bring up the point about what it is we are actually intending
this seal to do and I heard Superintendent Gordon speak to how this is going to motivate districts to engage their students and I do believe where it shows up as an accountability element does indicate or does have a change on how districts are motivated and whether or not we are going to truly create K-12 engagement.
So let me point out a particular story.
When I was a third grade teacher, I discovered, because my students told me, that the library in their community was open between 10 o'clock in the morning and 2 o'clock in the afternoon.
So I just need you to think about what's wrong with that picture.
So my students pointed this out, and I asked them, well, what is it you want to do?
Well, we would like the library hours to change so that it's available to us when we're actually out of school.
It's great during the summer because it gives them someplace to be during the hottest part of the day.
But during school time, it's never available to them because they lived in a low-income community.
All of those things that was where those kind of resources and access were difficult, that was something that had to be considered.
Those students wrote letters.
They went to their school board.
They went to the county and asked about why this was happening.
And because they made a big noise about it, I'm not going to say that the county wasn't already considering that or thinking that through.
But because they began hearing from students, those students felt heard.
But that was only one project.
But it was a very important and big project for them.
So I think that looking at the school climate piece,
that board member Burr is speaking about and the social emotional learning that this is supposed to, that this can connect to is very important.
So I think as we look at the criteria and look at
what it is we intend to use it for, and where we want to use it in the accountability system.
I would recommend at this point in time, let's get it off the ground.
And you know, I have always been the person to say, and what have we learned as a result of going forward with this?
I think we need to take the opportunity to get this off the ground, get it implemented.
And as it relates to then turning around and looking at accountability,
I would rather begin with a question, what did we learn as a result of implementing this to decide the best way to figure out how to hold schools accountable for how they use this to motivate their student group?
And I hope as we go forward, that's a way to look at it.
Any other?
Kim was next and then we'll come over to Felisa.
I have to say that I just have a visceral reaction to the idea of accountability and civic engagement in the same sentence.
There's something ultimately very aspirational about what we're trying to teach with civic engagement, and accountability has many connotations.
But I would hope this would be one where we could lead with carrot rather than stick.
because it is about inspiring rather than castigating anyone.
The other thing I just wanted to make explicit, because I was just looking at the language, I very much appreciate and resonate to how many folks have lifted up sort of the start early emphasis.
And as I've been thinking about elementary, I just want to make explicit that I,
There are about 300,000 preschool children who are served on elementary school campuses by school districts already.
It is not an uncommon practice to have things called way of counsel and preschool curriculum, which is about self-governance and agency and service learning, and that some of the language reflects elementary inclusion and starting early, and some of it is K-12, and it would just encourage us to think about pre-K-12 since school districts are already running so many of these programs.
Engagement for preschoolers, I love that.
Feliza.
Yes, absolutely.
Yeah, I just want to echo the.
The comments by board member Patio Bronson and, you know, I think people know I'm I'm very much accountability with a capital a. But when it comes to this, I just want kids to care about kids who are.
you know, locked up in a cage along the border and to do something about it.
I want kids to have empathy and understand that we are living in times where there's divisive rhetoric and that they could make a difference and that they could have youth voice and elevate the voice of others.
I want them to care.
I want them to act.
I want them to be civically engaged.
So for me, honestly, when it comes to this, it's less about the accountability and more about the character of the students that we have in our schools, making sure that in a school site, they're not chanting, build a wall, because we see reports about that, right?
So we want to make sure that our youth could have the heart and the mind to do act with character and act with conviction.
So that's what I want.
Well, I think in that aspect, it does go with social emotional learning, which I think is a great idea to look at it.
Thank you, Madam President board members, I want to ask 2 questions 1 about what kind of professional development might be available for teachers.
I.
Because these types of programs, I think sometimes when they get to the school level, it feels like an extra.
And people misinterpret things like criteria number one, must be in good standing, on track to graduate.
I could see someone misinterpreting that to say, oh, sorry, this student named Tony Thurman is not eligible to participate.
And I know that's not the intent.
And then just about professional development, I ask these things because,
Last year I had the good fortune to be able to spend almost a year as a guest instructor at the juvenile camp in Alameda County in partnership with the Alameda County Office of Education teaching a civics course.
The civics course layered very nicely with a course that the students were taking in history and government.
The students in the course went from questioning why we have to pay taxes in this country to recognizing how tax dollars pay for various services provided through government.
And then they went and they essentially lobbied their government, their county office, on what they thought should be in the LCAP.
And they came to the state legislature and they proposed a bill to help get kids out of the criminal justice system.
And I wish that there was an opportunity to provide those students
with the SEAL.
What I think it did provide them was an opportunity to think differently about education, meaning about concepts that they were learning that they couldn't previously apply to anything.
I think they began to see how it applied to their life and why they were learning what they were learning
And the experience of presenting a bill to legislators that actually was voted on, I think, means something.
And I've been able to work with three groups that have proposed legislation, and I think it is  I see how it fits within the framework of what you laid out.
And so I wanted to share the story because I'm listening to what many of you are saying about whether or not there should be an accountability focus
or where it should fit.
I would only offer, I'll let you all decide where it goes, I would only offer that for many students I have found that these types of opportunities do that thing that we keep saying we want, you know, students to do more around critical thinking, to make the learning feel more engaged to them.
And I'm very proud of the students that I've had the chance to work with and I hope we can give the seal
to as many students in the future as possible.
So having said that, could you talk about the professional development?
Because I would be concerned if people thought this is just an extra and instead of seeing how it could actually support almost any subject, I think the right kind of training could support that.
So thank you for that question.
There is quite a bit of professional development underway around civics education right now.
The 2017 Budget Act included $5 million for implementation of the history social science framework.
And our colleagues at Sacramento County Office of Education are now running, and I'm gonna read it so I don't mess it up, it's CLIC, but that's Content Literacy Inquiry and Citizenship Project.
And civics is one of the content areas specifically called out
in that budget language, so that we've got partners from NCFA California and the Constitutional Rights Foundation, subcontractors in that work, and they are helping educators across the state to support civics education in their school.
So there's some professional development happening statewide, specifically around civics education right now.
The Supreme Court Chief Justice and Superintendent are also involved in
power of democracy group.
And the justices use all these things I learned lately, they've got like this thing called judges in the classroom, where judges come to your school and help you understand how you can support civic education in your classroom with little little kids, right?
So there are a lot of different efforts going on.
I would say probably the biggest civics education professional development effort right now is happening within the context of that CLCC effort being led by Sacramento County.
But like our other communities of practice, I think we've had presentations around the math community of practice and the science community of practice.
We have a history of social science community practice with a special focus on civics.
So it's all 11 successor regions and the districts that they serve are engaged in this work.
So I think infusing information about the availability of the SEAL and how they can support students
to attain the SEAL, like kind of integrating into that existing history, social science infrastructure is a start.
We also have some work happening around environmental literacy, and we see that as a great opportunity to help students become more civically engaged.
So there's a lot of conversation around civics there.
There's already an infrastructure around that.
We can infuse information about the SEAL and how we help kids get to that SEAL, thinking about some of those environmental
community action projects around protecting the environment.
So there's work underway.
And again, our intent is to try and refine and hone and be able to like clearly make available to educators some of the pathways to help them support their kids to get here.
I think we've really given you a good hearing of the issues.
I don't know that we've given you consistent feedback, but you'll be talking to more stakeholders and coming back.
I would say with respect to the question of kind of how local and how standardized, I
I appreciate both of those arguments.
I think as part of the CCI, we really ought to be thinking of a CCCI, that is College Career and Civic Readiness.
And I would be interested in it becoming part of the CCI because we're trying to say with our dashboard and our state priorities, what is a whole education about?
What is a whole child?
being raised to do what we care about developing in the context of their opportunities to learn.
And I think this is one of the things that we clearly care about.
And leaving it out would diminish our image of what the whole education of the whole child is all about to some extent.
At the same time, I really appreciate the local control and the local indicators argument.
And I think it would be great to encourage
districts to do local indicators for civic engagement at elementary level, at middle school level, and put those in their local dashboards and reporting systems because we do want this to be throughout their school careers.
And so I hope we think of it broadly as serving many of the purposes because it is the foundation of our democracy.
And I appreciate all of the really important comments.
And I hope we make it available
to every student and eliminate any barriers to that being the case.
Thank you so much.
It's been a great conversation.
And we have done so well, board members, that we're actually going to take lunch and eat it together and not have to eat while we listen to commentaries.
So we'll resume at about 1245.
And we have lunch in the, yeah.
Good job.
Okay, I would like to reconvene the board and we will take up our consent calendars and welcome Stephanie Gregson to the table here.
First, I'd like to announce that W-18, the resource specialist waiver from Manteca has been pulled until September.
We'll hear it then.
And then we will take up the waiver consent items, waivers one through 15, 17, and 19.
We will have two votes on the waiver consent items because of member recusals.
And with waiver one, member Rucker, I believe you need to recuse yourself.
And is there any public comment on waiver one?
No?
Okay.
Do I have a motion?
Oh, sorry.
Let's get recusals out of the room.
Okay.
Nicky?
Yes.
Okay.
And do I have a second?
I'll second.
All those in favor say aye.
All those opposed?
Okay, motion carries.
We can ask Member Rucker to come right back.
Okay, next we will take action on the rest of waiver consent items 2 through 15, 17 and 19.
Is there any public comment on any of these waivers?
All right, are there any board member questions about any of the waivers?
All right, seeing none, do I have a motion?
I'll move.
Okay, member Sun, and a second?
I'll second.
Member Rucker?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Okay, we'll now take up waiver item 16 for separate action.
This is a request by the Natomas Unified School District to waive California Education Code section 56195.1A regarding size and scope requirements of a special education local plan area.
And Kristen Wright is going to lead us through that.
Thank you.
Afternoon.
Can you hear me?
Good afternoon, Kristen, right son is recuse special education said that out loud.
Yes.
So, uh, this waiver is, um.
For Natomas, unified school district requesting to become a single district.
So, currently a member of the Sacramento county.
The reason they're here for you today, as you've witnessed in the past for these other waivers of this type, they do not meet the size and scope spelled out in statute.
And so therefore, they are required to come to the board seeking a waiver to become a single district SELPA.
In the May meeting, two size and scope waivers were before you.
And during this meeting, we addressed to you in that there was very little criteria for us to recommend a denial of the waiver.
So just to let you know that we are currently, per your advice and request, working on developing some recommendations for you in the future to use for criteria.
But we didn't do it for this time yet since we so
It was so soon from the last time we saw you, but look for that in the future.
And we're working with board staff on that as well.
So in addition to.
you providing approval for the last ones, you approve those waivers for a period of one year.
So just reminding you about that.
And so to be consistent with those decisions that you made in May, we are recommending approval of this waiver with the one year.
So to provide the context, we provided state and federal data that you'll see there in your waiver package.
And the opposition that we had or that we found during our report was that we received opposition from the Natomas Teachers Association, which this was cited in the waiver request from the district, which just said citing teacher attrition and lack of classroom services and negative district culture.
So to address this opposition, we looked at any complaints filed in the last three years.
on behalf of students in Natomas.
And there were five complaints filed in the last three years.
Only one of those resulted in a finding.
So people allege complaints and then we investigate those complaints and look if they're in violation of the law.
None of them were except for one.
And the one was a child find issue, meaning that they felt the student needed to be tested.
Natomas corrected that and then was compliant.
So that's what we have in terms of data.
So I'm here for today.
Natomas is also here if you have questions for them, but to recommend approval conditions.
First, I want to ask Nikki Sandoval is our liaison, if she has any comments she'd like to make.
I actually have a question about there was correspondence from Natomas Charter School.
Just there was concern about language in the I'm looking for the exact reference.
Thank you.
And yes, and that actually was corrected when that was pointed out to us.
We went back in.
We asked Natomas to correct that language within their recommended plan.
They put that back through their entire process and met those requirements.
So that is no longer an issue.
Okay, so there's been ongoing communication and correspondence and addressing issues that come up in real time.
Yes.
And they met those requirements.
And like I said, took it back through their process of getting it approved through their boards and everything and also through Sac County.
Okay.
Thank you.
And thank you for also looking at and describing the findings and the complaints.
That's very important.
And I do look forward to hearing more recommendations from the Department on the policy and how we can have just better guidelines in place for addressing these requests as they come up.
But I do feel that operating under the constraints of the existing policy that we're working with
And the research you've done, I support the department's recommendation as it's written and for a one-year waiver for this particular request.
Are there any clarifying questions at this point?
We'll come back with a fuller discussion after public comment, but clarifying questions?
Yes, board member Navo.
When we give them the one year, assuming they don't get it the next year, so all of the students then would have to go back into the county SELPA?
Assuming that if it wasn't granted, if the waiver wasn't granted next year, we have never faced that.
And so technically, I guess, yes.
What do you think?
Yes.
Yeah.
It would revert back.
Or we would have to figure out with them what their options were.
Because you can seek another SELPA.
Yeah.
OK.
Until the department clarifies the size and scope issues with regards to waivers, we're probably going to be in these one-year approvals, approval with conditions up until we get it.
That's up to you guys.
But we're here to serve.
So we realize that you need more information.
And so we're all trying to work collaboratively to make sure that we're being fair and across everyone.
Because I know these have become more and more over the last few years.
And so it's sort of a new world around this.
And so we're happy to provide you with whatever information you need.
But again, each of the things that come up, like that question, is another ponderance of,
Okay, we haven't faced that before.
What do we do?
Any other clarifying questions?
Is there any public comment?
No public comment.
So are there any other areas of discussion that people wanna raise about this?
You were sort of, both Nikki and Matt were raising the point that we need more criteria for these.
The other thing that I think we're seeing is that this is now, we've had many of these requests to leave the SELPAs the,
idea of having a conglomerate is in part to spread the risk for high need students, et cetera.
Clearly the system we have in the state is not working uniformly at this point.
It's an old system that kind of grew up over time.
And I think in addition to thinking about criteria for leaving a SELPA, we need to have a broader conversation about what
the governance structure should be for special education in the state.
So I'm just flagging that this is kind of a minor symptom of a major issue that we should both take up in its immediate presentation, but in a broader way.
So we'll look forward to further conversations with you, Kristen, on these issues.
Are there any other points of
clarification, discussion, questions that we want to raise before we vote.
All right.
Can I have a motion?
I move CDE's recommendation to approve the waiver for one year.
Thank you very much.
A second?
I'll second.
Matt, thank you very much.
No further discussion.
All in favor, say aye.
Any opposed, say nay.
Any abstentions?
All right.
Motion passes.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Kristen.
She's already gone.
So we can ask Member Sun to return.
And now we have to take up seven through 13, right?
Yeah.
Right.
So now we're gonna take up the regular consent items, items five and seven through 13.
Are there any public comments?
Yes, one for item five, C.T.
Turner, and two for item 10, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz and Dean Drescher.
Thank you.
around adult education and high school equivalency.
And we're proud of the success and the outcomes that we've produced with the GED program for adult learners in California, helping them prepare for college programs and for today's jobs.
We think the data that's provided, inputs, process data on high school equivalency in the board packet is important, but we also believe it's very important in these discussions to talk about data and outcomes.
And so we provided some additional information for you on that as part of your packet.
The board in 2014, when they approved multiple tests, asked that someone track this data and present it back to the board to look at the efficacy and how these tests were performing and how graduates were actually doing.
So that's something that we're trying to do today is provide you some of that information.
We've also provided some high-level information about some of the programs that we created, like free testing for employees at several large companies for those students in those companies in California.
And then also some other things that we've developed.
Time.
All right.
And beyond the things that we've developed to help adult learners, I just wanted to, in California, I wanted to say that we are the lowest cost test also still in California.
So happy to discuss any of that data if you all desire.
Thank you.
President Dolling-Hammond, members of the board, Dean Drescher here on behalf of EdVoice.
I made it in time.
I just wanted to say regarding item 10, we read the grant application on the literacy plan.
And quite frankly, we were hoping for a little bit of a clearer understanding after reading the plan.
We were hoping there would be more specificity referencing the research proven methods for teaching reading as is currently in the Education Code already.
Much of what is referenced in the Ed Code is also in the Federal Register, the outline of what needs to be in the grant and the grant opportunity.
But that doesn't explicitly seem to be stated in the grant that I read.
And so we would encourage that adding that as an emphasis on science-based reading instruction is important as it's what's been proven to help kids learn how to read.
Thank you.
Another public comment?
Okay.
Liz.
Sorry, I didn't sign up because I thought Martha was going to be here.
Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
In the letter that we submitted for the Equity Coalition, we wanted to raise the fact that we're pleased about the literacy grant application coming out, but we were disappointed that
It didn't include the terms biliteracy and focus on biliteracy, especially considering the overwhelming support for Prop 58 recently and our adoption and embrace of the English learner roadmap.
So we hope that that can be included in our application or in the RFP.
Thanks.
Thank you.
At this point, is there any other board discussion on any of the items?
Lisa?
I just want to say that if granted the literacy grant from the feds, we will make sure, I will commit from the state board perspective to make sure that my literacy is highlighted throughout and threaded well, as well as the EL policy and the EL roadmap.
Any other comments or discussion?
Yes, Patricia.
I just wanted to support what board member Ortiz-Lacombe said.
I also agree we need to make sure that that is done.
we do receive the literacy grant, there will be a lot of opportunity for really thinking and shaping.
It came out from the federal government with only one month to reply.
We ended up with only two weeks to reply, so it was a very rushed process, but there, I know, is quite a lot of openness to really digging in if the grant is received.
All right, if there's no other discussion, do I have a motion to approve these consent items?
Thank you.
Any opposed?
Nay?
Any abstentions?
Motion passes.
Thank you.
This is the moment you've all been waiting for.
Item six is our annual review of the school accountability report card.
This is the exciting part of the agenda.
Approve the template for the 2018-19 school accountability report card.
And the item will be presented by Cindy Kazanas of the California Department of Education.
And as soon as you're ready, Cindy, feel free to begin.
Thank you, good afternoon, Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis Measurement Accountability Reporting Division.
Since I've been Director, this is my, going on my fourth year, this is the first time I've had the opportunity to talk to you about the school accountability report card.
So, we have always been on consent, it's always nice to highlight something that has been in our state constitution for over 30 years now.
So this is something that is approved on the annual basis by you all.
and it is based on information.
The information that's included is the most recently available data, so trying to pick it up from the prior year.
Something that is changed from this last year is we are slowly increasing the amount that we're pre-populating for the template, so we're trying to reduce the data burden.
for our local educational agencies and schools.
This year we anticipate being able to pre-populate 90%.
The remaining 10% includes information such as teacher credentialing information, which we'll pick up next year, Williams quality, currency, availability of textbooks, school facilities, and expenditures per pupil and school site teacher salaries.
That is all inputted at the local level.
So what's before you today is a request for approval of the SARC template.
We thought that we would talk through what is the normal flow for the SARC, and those of you that have had a role at the school and district level, I'm sure you can speak from experience how this actually works operationally.
But because the board traditionally approves this in July, it gives us roughly two months to work with the contractor, which is San Joaquin County Office of Education,
put information out through the application, the edit field, make sure for data quality purposes that you've got everything there.
And then we'll release it to LEAs for use in October.
So LEAs then sort of take it from there.
Some of them will take it directly to their board in November or December for approval because it has to be approved by their local board of education.
So that has to be, of course, agendized and such.
Ultimately, if you go down to the bottom, the February 1st deadline is a constitutional deadline that cannot be moved.
So, working backwards, some of the letters that talked about this item were concerned about the California assessment on science and the inability for the state to pre-populate that data and there was a suggestion made that locals could pre-populate it.
So, Michelle's Center is here if you have any technical questions.
Because this is the first year of results for the science test, we have suggested a placeholder on the template, knowing that next year we will catch up and we'll have two years of data for the science test.
You have a responsibility or you have a role in approving the threshold scores in November.
And so for between November and January, assuming that you approve those scores, as Michelle recommends, there is a great deal of work that is done by the contractor and by the department and LEAs to make sure that the data quality is there.
So with all of that said,
That is why we came up with a recommendation for a placeholder and not the ability to put the actual scores in because we will Not have enough time to place those scores In there, but again when we when we come back again next year And if this is on consent you will see the ability for the two years of data to be in this ARC template So I'm happy to respond to any questions or again Michelle is available as well
Are there any clarifying questions?
There's a placeholder for the science scores that's populated by the LEAs, right?
Or the schools?
It's not.
It just says it's a placeholder saying that this information due to timing is not available this year.
You know, we will add this to the scores will be included in the next year's template.
Got it.
Exactly.
I want to see if Suber or Eileen Strauss as our liaisons want to make some framing comments for us.
I just wanted you to refresh my memory, Cindy, about the science test scores.
Will they be on the dashboard ahead of the template?
They will not.
We do have language in the dashboard saying that we're going to work on incorporating those scores, but we don't, again, have enough years of data even to think about how to incorporate them.
So I just, did you ask about framing comments too?
Okay.
So as Cindy noted, this does typically go on consent because it is, you know, just kind of regular business that we do it.
But it is, I think, appropriate at this point, since we are pretty well built out with the dashboard, to once again evaluate whether or not there's a way for a true merger of the two.
and or some statutory change that says, and I know it's in Prop 98, that's how we got the school accountability report card 30 years ago, that there's some statutory statement made by the legislature and affirmed by the governor that the dashboard meets the intent of the SARC.
Because to continue to do these two things, even though I know you guys have done an amazing job,
of limiting workload.
It just doesn't make sense to me anymore.
It's confusing.
It's just kind of an overwhelming amount of stuff.
So that's just my editorial comment.
So first, thank you for the update, Cindy.
And I think just a recognition as a former district leader and site leader who completed these things, the fact that the pre-population is so extensive, I know Matt and I would really
appreciate that service from CDE from having had to fill those in.
And then I just want to make a comment about science because I think we've been working for a long time on science, but it takes a long time.
And so kind of to remind people that while we adopted the standards many years ago, the materials were reviewed and approved last November.
which means districts began to review the materials for potential adoption for aligned materials just in the spring.
And not everybody has yet purchased aligned materials.
And what we know about standards adoptions is it takes a long time.
These science standards are completely organized very differently from all that we had done 20 years ago.
I mean, there are new standards that were very well embraced and we needed them in the field.
But I think in fairness,
Teachers and leaders are getting used to the new standards, understanding the standards, now are looking for aligned materials, doing some online, some different training.
And then we did a field test and pilot to get a reliable assessment.
And still in November, we will work on setting cut scores.
So once those things are done, I think site and district leaders need to communicate with their stakeholders
about what the assessments mean, what it means for the standards, what the standards are.
It's not the only standards we've adopted lately.
And so I think being respectful that it takes time to communicate that.
and have teachers align their professional development to implement that.
I think the fact that you have it's coming and there's actually a box on the SARC is great because it says that we're working on, we just don't have the scores yet.
But I think timeliness means in January, schools will have some cut scores once we establish them.
And then it's, we're already in the spring semester by then.
So I think by next fall, then we will have been working on it, we will have expected people to do aligned materials and
then we'll have two years of scores.
So I just think we want to communicate as board members that we care and are committed to implementation of our science standards, but it takes a while and that this is a new assessment.
So I appreciate the holding spot on the SARC.
I know that we've been looking at that on the dashboard and we had committed that on the dashboard when we had reliable data, we would put that on our dashboard.
Any other clarifying questions and then we'll have public comment and come back for deeper questions.
You're okay.
Okay, I will do public comment and then we'll come back for discussion.
Danielle Duarte and Jessica Sacco.
So my name is Danielle Duarte, and I am currently an education leadership doctoral student at Harvard, and formerly worked here in California as a school counselor, and was the president of the California Association of School Counselors.
So as updates are being made to this arc, I wanted to suggest another.
Page 15 includes two charts.
One that's the ratio of academic counselors to pupils, and the second that says support staff, that includes another line that says counselors, academic, social behavioral, or career development.
California Ed Code 49600 defines educational counseling as that provided by a school counselor with a valid credential to, quote, plan, implement, and evaluate programs to promote the academic, career, personal, and social development of all pupils.
So therefore, the counseling fields on the SARC don't align with Ed Code and actually lead to confusion when folks are completing the document.
So I have two primary suggestions.
One is to change from academic counseling to school counseling with the parentheses academic, social, behavioral, and career development.
And then the second is to add PPS credentialed before school counseling along with psychologists and social workers to get a better understanding of the support staff in the schools because it's unclear, for example, if psychologist means a clinical psychologist or a PPS psychologist.
So thank you so much for your consideration.
Good afternoon, Jessica Sacco with the California STEM Network, a project of Children Now.
As has been discussed, the cast results are not yet on the dashboard and they are probably a couple of years out based on the understanding of our conversations that have been had thus far around those results.
We also understand and respect the timeline that has been laid out so completely by CDE staff.
However, we do ask that consideration be made in order to consider whether or not instructions could be provided in case data is available if an LEA chooses how to complete this table if it's feasible.
Not that it would be required, but that if it's feasible.
It's a may rather than shall, if you will.
We are interested really in just keeping this information as readily accessible as possible to parents and stakeholders and keeping it in the forefront of planning, budgeting, as has been discussed, implementation, investments still need to be made in these standards, and this is part of that planning, budgeting consideration process, and we'd like to keep that in the forefront.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
I just want to thank member Burr for her comments relative to looking at some possible changes for demonstrating that the dashboard meets the intent of the SARC and therefore replaces, as we've talked time and time again, we'd rather have our folks implementing rather than writing.
And we don't have enough people to do both in our small districts.
So we would love to work with you, work with board and CDE staff to make some kind of a change if that's the will of the board, because we think that would be very, very helpful out in the field.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
I wanted to speak to the integration of the SARC elements with the dashboard.
At Public Advocates, we strongly believe that there does need to be a more integrated tool.
so that parents and community members and organizers aren't going to two different documents.
But I would say that we still have not completed that integration.
We appreciate very much working with the department staff to figure out ways to make that happen.
And as Ms.
Kozanas stated earlier, a couple of items that have been added to the SARC by statute are the result of a settlement in Williams.
And they are the whether standards aligned instructional materials and facilities and good repair.
And until we figure that out, we would not be, we would not support identifying that the dashboard meets Prop 98.
And we hope to continue collaborating on this so that we can get it right.
Thank you.
We're now open for further discussion.
Member Rucker, did you want to dive in there and are there others who want to be in the queue?
The school accountability report card.
It's something everybody loves and they would love to have specific items in there, but they also want it to be easy to read.
I was touched by what the, and affected by what the
the soon-to-be doctor from Harvard talked about concerning the reporting template, especially when she got to page 15.
If I had to fill out a report card, a 15-page report card for each of the students that I taught, I would have lost my mind.
So I'm all in favor
of the idea of figuring out how to consolidate the use of the dashboard and the elements that are reported in the SARC.
But there are some elements that are unique to the SARC that I'm not sure we can contemplate how to put those into
the dashboard without it becoming an accountability element.
I'm speaking, I'm thinking in particular of the three fiscal reporting requirements that were added to the SARC by ESSA.
In particular, the per pupil report, accountability reporting from all funds, from all revenue streams of funds, both federal and state, that both the district and each school site must have in their SARC.
The problem with combining the SARC and adding that particular unique element is if a member of the public sees a data element like that in an accountability document, it changes what has purely been
intended for information purposes to a different conversation about school fiscal accounting.
It will stop being an accounting information item and become a fiscal accountability item.
So in making the determination to blend
these two documents, we do have to think about what elements are actually quite unique to the SARC that are different from the dashboard.
I also think it's important for us to remember that for a lot of people, because the SARC is a 30-year-old document, it's become a part of the culture of the schools and a culture of the conversation that many communities and many stakeholder communities
actually organize their discussion and their data points in their discussions about, particularly with their local school districts.
I've done a lot of school site council trainings in my other profession, in my other life.
And a lot of parents, when they come to those school site council meetings, they talk about that SARC.
So, it is an important document.
While it may not be important to us, the reality is it is very important in many, many communities.
Yes, Felisa.
I'm glad you brought that up, Board Member Rucker, because I was looking at this and I was wondering where are the ESSA requirements here in terms of the local level expenditures?
I see.
But where is it on the.
It's not required until next year.
OK, because I see the narrative provided by LEA, but it's not broken down.
So David Sapp, Assistant Counsel State Board of Education.
Point of clarification, the federal law requires report cards for local educational agencies in the state.
It does not require school level report cards.
The SARC, the School Accountability Report Card, is purely a function of state law.
It is not needed to meet federal requirements.
So I just wanted to clarify that point.
that the elements in the SARC are not specifically tied to ESSA.
Now, to the extent the question is whether the elements required in SARC should be the same data points or whether they need to be included, that's more of a policy discussion, but the underlying legal foundation is that there is no required school report card for federal requirements.
And so, as we're thinking, and I know you said that this has been historically on consent, and I'm thinking next year, we're probably going to have to revisit because we have a new graduation rate that is not reflected here.
So, here is based on four years.
If you look at this template, it's reporting on a four-year graduation rate.
Next year, it might look different.
No, this would remain as a four year graduation rate.
So, you know, I think to member Burr's point, there's not been a crosswalk done.
It's been approved by the legislature.
The department proposed legislation last year and the legislation was not successful.
So we have made attempts to to make that crosswalk, but there is none.
So it would revert back to the federal definition, which is the adjusted cohort.
Okay, because the other piece that I was looking at was under priority four, the percentage of students who have successfully completed courses that satisfy the UC or the CSU.
And typically, we see that as A through G, correct?
If the CSU changes that requirement, that's going to have, hopefully they don't.
But if they add that fourth year math, yes, do you see my platform?
We would have to also adjust there, correct?
There are things in this template that change every year.
Every year you get it back.
So I don't know that we've had a year that we've missed bringing it to you for edits.
Yeah, but maybe not on consent.
I'm just saying the next year we may have to look at it again.
Thank you.
Anything else that you'd like to inform us on of the thinking of this integration of the of the documents?
Are there any other?
So I would say to go back to the to item one, when I talked about that, the good news was that the governor's budget provided some extra money for accountability.
One of the pieces is to start providing a technical platform, a foundation on the technical side, because the contractor is the same person.
Right.
It's San Joaquin County Office of Education has
deliberately been selected by the administration to manage the SARC and the dashboard.
And so to start looking at things like the Williams pieces, because there are pieces of a local indicator that ask for the same information, to figure out how to start integrating that.
So there is the first phase of that is funded for this year.
So we will begin, we are going to be beginning work on that.
I think we have a meeting with Samaki in the next week or two.
So it's a multi-year project.
It's not something that can be solved overnight.
But to the point about legislation, there is pieces of legislation that would probably be necessary to make any major changes to the SARC.
We just keep nibbling around the edges where we can to make it as user-friendly and to the letter of the law.
All right, well, we'll be hearing more about this.
Thank you very much.
I think we need to make a motion to accept this report or template.
I move the department's recommendation.
And is that member Rucker who said that?
OK, great.
No further discussion.
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
All right.
Motion passes.
Thank you very much.
So rolling right along, agenda item 14 is the State Board Projects and Priorities.
And that includes our future meeting plans, agenda items, et cetera.
We wanna start with a motion from a board member to approve the May 7th State Board of Education Study Session Draft Preliminary Report of Action slash Minutes.
That's a long title.
I move approval.
I'll move approval.
I'm not done, but I'll tell you the... And the May 8th and 9th, 2019 State Board of Education Draft Preliminary Report of Action slash Meeting Minutes.
Now, Member Strauss.
I move approval.
Thank you very much.
I know, I took a breath.
I shouldn't have done that.
Is there a second?
I'll second.
Thank you, Member Rucker.
Any discussion of the minutes?
All right.
Very good.
All in favor say aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Motion carries.
Now I want to invite the board members to report on any liaison activities that are not related to any items on our agenda.
And I'll just call us by name alphabetically and we'll move through.
You can pass if you need to but I'm sure most of you have something to say.
So member Burr.
Thank you.
I'd just like to report about the June 6th meeting of the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, known as CCEE.
First, we were delighted to welcome a new member.
Our county superintendent representative is now Karen Monroe from the Alameda County Office of Education.
She replaces Michael Watkins, who retired.
She's going to be a fantastic addition.
She has lots of experience in urban education.
and also in charter school authorization.
The collaborative is going to move to a quarterly meeting schedule.
We were meeting every other month and we felt like we were sufficiently burdened with other activities and that a quarterly meeting schedule would be fine.
Our next meeting will be December 5th in San Diego.
So we're moving around once a year.
And that's going to be held at the San Diego County Office of Education, but in conjunction with CSBA.
So folks who are interested in attending the California School Boards Association annual conference will have the ability to do that.
We had two presentations that I thought were quite helpful.
One was from the Vallejo Unified School District, and many of you will remember that Vallejo is one of the districts that's in fiscal distress.
And under legislation that changed last year, the collaborative has a key role.
along with the department and the county office in providing really deep support and assistance to those districts.
And the superintendent from Vallejo came and spoke about how helpful that had been and the kinds of things they were trying to change in the district.
So if you're interested in that, all of it's available on archive.
We also had a very enlightening and I think relevant discussion to our conversation this morning from one of our professional learning networks that was headed by the California Association of African American Administrators.
They've been meeting together as a professional learning network over the last couple of years and talked about that.
And they've actually released a report called Equity in Action that contains a number of recommendations.
And I think apropos to Board Member Rucker's comment earlier on this topic, it's very consistent with what we found a couple of years ago and the recommendations that were made by our African American Advisory Council.
So I commend that to the superintendent, especially for the work on closing the achievement gap.
That is available also for everybody to see on the collaborative's website.
I just wanted to mention briefly two budget initiatives that were funded.
We talked about the good news in the budget.
There's $14 million that's provided in the budget for the California 21st Century School Leadership Academy.
It's a reboot of the School Leadership Academy.
The grant will be co-administered by the collaborative and the department and will provide grants to local education agencies, non-profits, and others for professional development opportunities for administrators.
Related to that, a very nice marriage, $38 million provided for educational workforce investment grants, also to be co-administered by the collaborative and the department.
And this is for professional development for teachers.
Of that amount, $10 million is called out specifically for professional development related to the English Learner Roadmap.
The rest of the money seems to be fairly open-ended, but it's related to content standards and social-emotional learning, the kinds of things that we're trying to promote in the LCAP.
So that's very exciting that those funds are available.
And I think lots of questions that were asked this morning about professional development for various activities, hopefully some of that can be realized with that money.
That's my report, thank you.
All right, thank you.
And remember coding this?
Your last words.
Yeah, my last words.
So in May, I went to the Youth Action Summit in Oakland, which is hosted by All-City Council Student Union, which is a student union that was created in the 70s in Oakland.
And what they did was reflect on the year, because as you know, in Oakland, there is a teacher strike and a lot of students were talking about
Where do students go from there?
And so being there, it was really great because I was a senior and I was also there as a state board member and being there, a lot of students got to really talk about, okay, what are the next steps as students to build relationships with adults to see how we can improve education?
I feel that that's a conversation we all should be having about instead of students taking over, instead of adults taking over, how do we build partnerships and relationships?
so that when doing this work, people are doing it together.
They also elected a whole new governing board for their student union and two new student board members, Micah Smith and Denilson.
And so I'm very excited for them.
That's really all I have to report on.
But I'm really honored to be a part of this board again.
You know, it's kind of sad to be going because, you know, I was just getting comfortable.
You know, maybe I could try to come back.
I don't know.
And
Yeah, that's kind of something small.
And after, if we could take a picture together, I would really appreciate it.
You know, kind of get those memories.
So thank you.
I know there are a lot of people who want their picture taken with you so that we will definitely do that.
Remember Navajo?
Well, I'm not on any liaisons yet, but I will say I wish this was my first board meeting as opposed to the last one.
This has been a great one today.
But I have enjoyed it so far, and I'm looking forward to my assignments and having things to report.
And I don't know you very well, Ms.
Cardenas, but I wish you well.
And I'm proud of you, and I believe your little sister, she has a great woman to look up to.
I have two brief updates regarding the health framework and also the Ethnic Studies Model Curriculum.
But before I do, I just wanted to say that it's been an honor serving with you, Gemma.
Gemma Quetzal.
Gemma means jewel in Spanish and Quetzal is actually a beautiful bird.
It's the national bird of Guatemala.
But it's been, and I think it's very symbolic of who you are, because you have really soared.
You've brought a voice to this boardroom that has not been heard before.
And so I appreciate everything you've done.
I know you must be very proud of Vida.
Vida is on her track to mead.
your accomplishments.
You remind me a lot of who I was as a high school student from West Long Beach, except you're far more accomplished than I ever was as a high school student.
But I wish you the best at Stanford.
I think Stanford made the right choice, but I think that they're going to learn more from you.
then you probably learn from them.
No, not.
It's just that there's there's a different voice and experience that you're bringing to that campus.
So congratulations.
My report.
So we the health framework is approved.
We approved it in May, but now we need the materials.
And so we also approved the timeline for
the reviewer application.
And so, we will be, the window to apply to be a reviewer has closed, I believe.
It's July 2019.
We will be appointing reviewers to the review panel.
So, November 2019, we'll be approving
only the reviewers, and they will now be working to look at all the materials and forward the recommendations to the IQC.
Please expect to have some initial recommendations September 2020, with the final recommendations November 2020.
Okay, so it's a good timeline.
There'll be plenty of opportunity for the public to weigh in.
We know that this is a topic of interest.
Another topic of interest is the Ethnic Studies Model Curriculum.
So the State Board, we approved a group of teachers and college-level faculty with ethnic studies expertise and classroom experience, and they comprise the Model Curriculum Advisory Committee.
They met over the course of three different times, and they have now submitted a draft to the IQC for approval.
This draft is currently under public review, and so we will have a public comment period until August 15th of 2019.
We will, the IQC will bring it up September 19 of 2019, and we could expect to have a recommendation to us sometime in 2020.
So I will keep you posted.
I'm following it all very closely.
Thank you.
Member Patil-Branson.
I will actually just start by saying thank you for my liaison assignment.
I got to have the experience of working on the seal of civic engagement and what a lovely first experience it was and was really happy to work with the department staff and the state board staff.
made it very easy, and I think it's also just very grounding to think of the work of the State Board as work about transformation, as well as all of the individual educational inputs that we also are very much thinking about and are essential to our work.
In my other hat of thinking about how to make sure that we're thinking about prevention, about getting ahead of the achievement gap before it rears its head, and also about early learning and education, I'll just share a couple of highlights from the state budget that was just signed by the governor.
I don't know if these have ever traditionally been part of the updates that come to the state board, but there are significant investments, I think, that were made in the budget adopted by the governor and the legislature.
So I'll just highlight a couple.
There was almost $200 million in new funding for access to child care and preschool programs.
Interestingly, using a combination of federal funds, general fund, but also Prop 64, which is cannabis funding around the idea that
education and child strengthening and prevention begins at birth and also with parenting programs as well as educational programs.
It's a zero to 12 set of programs that encompass after school as well as preschool.
There's also $273 million in the state budget for early care and education facilities, $195 million for early learning workforce development, a special call out for emergency child care and early learning opportunities for foster families.
and $5 million to support the development of a master plan for early childhood development, which our own Linda Darling-Hammond will be one of the leaders on, which is very exciting.
I'll note that I think this is actually something new and it is a precedent for the state board to be named as a integral player in the development of a early childhood master plan.
There are a couple of states around the country that have
created these in the past and some other states have sort of fallen into involving their state boards of ed and their K to 12 systems after the fact and I'm really proud of us that we're getting it right from the start.
affordability earlier this week.
And it was a very good meeting.
It was a nice conversation to meet with stakeholders from a lot of different interest groups and interest areas across the state to talk about the issue of college affordability and a recognition of the superintendent's role in that conversation.
I thought it was engaging and it was a wonderful opportunity.
So I was grateful to be there to listen to the staff who facilitated the meeting.
They did an excellent job.
And they were definitely a credit not only to the department, but to the community of California stakeholders who are gaining a reputation across the country about this thing that we're calling the California Way.
So it was a wonderful opportunity to get to see.
So I want to encourage, I want to encourage any of my other colleagues on the board who haven't had an opportunity to go to any of the work group meetings.
I certainly encourage you to do that.
I will save any conversation about the other, the pathways, the career educational pathways for my colleague.
Ting Sun and for the IQC for my colleague Eileen Strauss.
I do want to talk about two other assignments I had.
Earlier this month and earlier in June, actually, I attended at the invitation of the Early Math Symposium Project.
I attended the early math conference that was held in the Bay Area in Hayward.
I want to thank Carolyn Pfister and her staff for the work they did to put together another fantastic program and excellent conference.
The idea of early, not only early childhood education, but early math instruction
Not only is an important topic, but this conference is coming at a time when California is getting a chance to revisit the decisions it made with the development of the math framework.
That was one of the first assignments I received as a member of the board and I'm happy to get a chance to be on the board as we
go back now and come full circle to take a look at a math instruction and take a look at what we learned from the implementation of the standards.
That was the first framework that we wrote.
I saw a lot of good instruction and a lot of good guidance and modeling on good first instruction in math.
And as we go through this process of developing the new math framework and talking about curriculum, I'm going to give you the same charge that Carolyn gave to the participants
at that conference.
I want you to think about who your math champion was.
And when we get to teacher appreciation next spring, I'm going to share my story about who my math champion was because it's very important for us to think about those things because it informs what it is we do to help students not only become good students, but to appreciate math as a discipline and not simply decide they hate math or that they're not good at math.
The other area that the other project that I participated in and had a chance to attend was the stakeholder, the stakeholder work group on significant disproportionality.
The department is working very closely with this work group to formulate recommendations for how the state can address not only identifying LEAs where this is an issue, but also to develop a process for intervention to help them decide how they're going to resolve
this particular identification issue.
I want to thank Kristen Wright and her staff in the department for facilitating this work.
It is not a department project.
This is very much work that's being done by stakeholders and they are taking on the responsibility, the very challenging responsibility
of helping these stakeholders to develop their recommendation and their report, which I anticipate we will get a chance to see later on this fall after it has been reviewed and vetted by our advisory commission on special education.
So those two projects, both the math project and the issue on significant disproportionality
had been a very important passion project for me during my tenure on the board and I'm very happy to see this conversation maturing and policy ideas to develop to address this particular perspective are coming to fruition.
That's my report.
Thank you.
Member Sandoval.
Hey, visual and performing arts and liaison on that wonderful issue and the curriculum framework and evaluation criteria development is underway for the visual and performing arts standards.
So stay tuned for that a few more meetings and then starting on the 13th of this month.
525 emerging artists and creators will start the 33rd session of the California State Summer School for the Arts in Valencia.
So it's a four-week intensive residential program.
Wonderful outcomes there.
So I will give you more information on that at our next meeting as far as a breakdown and representation because I do like to share that.
The school does a phenomenal job of outreach and making sure that we have representation from throughout the state geographically.
And the Advisory Commission on Special Education met on June 19th.
I attended that meeting, and I'm just going to pull a few highlights.
They have two really full days of meetings and discussions, but I'm just going to highlight a few items for you.
We heard a report on the work to develop a comprehensive integrated system of care by breaking barriers between agencies.
I learned that the leading cause of the healthcare system burden is mental health and addiction.
I know that's not a surprise, but 75% of mental illness manifests prior to age 14, but the average delay between the onset of symptoms and intervention is 10 years.
And as we know, youth suicide is of epidemic proportions.
That's the fact.
And children are becoming younger and younger when they develop suicidal ideation.
And so we heard a report on that work.
And then we also heard a panel on diploma options for students with significant cognitive disabilities.
And according to some of the presenters with the California Transition Alliance, by next year, 65% of all jobs will require post-secondary education and training.
Only 74% of our students with disabilities earn a high school diploma.
And only 9.2% of our students with disabilities are meeting college and career readiness standards.
And that's compared to 42.4% of all students.
So as we know, not having a diploma is a significant barrier to employment.
So stark and startling statistics, but I think that we're all focused on developing systems of support and working with youth and families and our teachers and administrators in a way we're getting more coherence in our system and recognizing that they're all of these factors that come into play and I think we're moving on a good path.
So that concludes my liaison report.
President Strauss.
So I lay us under the Concurrence Commission, which is the subject matter projects, and we meet twice a year.
We met the beginning of June in Oakland.
Just because there's some new funding, finally, for the subject matter projects, just to remind people that the goal of the subject matter projects is to support highly effective teaching, support English language learning and academic literacy, technical assistance to partner schools and districts, and to assess the impact of PD, and then also to look at the challenges going forward.
We talked a lot about professional development.
This is the time of year where each project gives the report on what they're actually doing and what their goals are based on the current standards and frameworks.
It's actually really exciting to think about.
So just to remind you, because I'm not sure if you're aware of all the different subject matter projects, but we have an arts project.
We have a global education project, a history, social science project, a math project.
physical education health project, reading and literature, a science project, a writing project, a world language project.
So these are ongoing based with university and partners across the state.
So there's not just like one math center, but there's a head of each of the projects.
So actually really exciting, took a look at the projects that they're working on statewide.
One really exciting thing that we're working on together
is a CSU-UC Environmental and Climate Change Literacy Summit.
So that came out of last year's climate literacy summit that we had right around, there's one in the Bay Area.
This will be at UCLA, and it has actually been rescheduled now till December.
So we get one spot at meetings, a couple hundred people, but we'll be anxious to hear about that.
So I thought I'd share that.
And then also I was fortunate to be invited to attend the California Collaborative on District Reform of which member Navo is a member.
And they talked particularly about using data to support improvement, building systems and changing culture.
And this really is timely with the commitment to expand and coordinate our statewide data systems.
So there was actually a panel, state agencies talking about what the next steps are.
But I thought I'd share with you a couple highlights about the challenges that districts are facing, the communication issues around community stakeholders, and that's a public website if you're interested at all.
The collaborative does a great job.
These are funded by
And they do a great job before each meeting of supporting reading that prepares you for the meeting.
It's been going on for 13 years.
They meet three times a year.
It's really exciting.
It's a group of districts and state leaders and researchers that really work together.
My curse was there.
Really exciting to hear some of the work.
But what are the conditions for teachers to do their best work?
How do you integrate and braid resources?
what's the system capacity to use the data?
We were talking before about, so you have the data, how do you understand how to use it?
We had presentations from districts like Long Beach, Sac City, districts that are talking about how they use it in their district, what they're doing with our dashboard, what they're doing with state measures, what they're doing with local measures, what needs we have going forward.
Sarah was there the second day listening to kind of impact for state data systems.
So I think really there's a lot of
hard work going on in the field trying to make the best of what we do to improve systems.
And I think the issue is really how do we keep guiding continual improvement and how do we make progress?
We're a big state.
We're diverse.
So the collaborative was a really wonderful two days, really intense.
I'm going to give you a CTC update in a minute.
Starting today through Friday is the Education Commission of the States meeting and because we only meet for one day I'll actually get to go and so Lupita will be presenting on Friday.
Our dashboard is part of a couple state team and I'm going to be there to be her cheerleader and support her but as part of the State Commission.
Commissioner, I get the opportunity to go twice a year, so we'll be meeting in Denver later this week.
And then, just CTC quickly, we have a lot of credentials that we're trying to update and revise standards, so we looked at the education, they met in June also, the educational specialist program standards, and there's budget funding to create an educational specialist performance assessment, and so there was some discussion about that.
I'll just kind of highlight a couple of things.
And then we also looked at the early childhood special education authorization.
So a lot of talk about that.
We know that's a really critical time to help kids develop.
And so they talked a lot about the different categories.
All the documents are available, but I just wanted to share that with you.
Also, taking a look at concurrent bilingual candidates who are working on teacher education and how we look at assessments for making sure that we have ability to teach English learners in our programs.
And we know that's really important through all the work we do in the population.
I think 93% of all teachers in the state of California have English learners in their classrooms.
It's a really important issue.
So the Credential Commission is continuing to try to update that.
And then they're still working on re-looking at the teacher performance assessment with all the new standards that we've continued to adopt to make that current as well.
And yeah, I think those are the highlights for some of the things that we're talking about.
So that's the end of my report.
Thanks.
I always get to go after Board Member Stroud.
I'm like such a slacker.
All right.
Well, a school.
So, I'm going to report on California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
So, as President Darling-Hammond mentioned at the very beginning of the meeting,
We're very pleased that Perkins V transition plan was approved by the U.S.
Department of Education, so that ensures flow of funding for the next fiscal year.
So we're going to immediately start on the Perkins V plan.
And so we are meeting on Friday, this Friday, a day from now.
And so that's when we'll look at timelines and how we will be engaging stakeholders in the Perkins V plan.
The other big item that we'll be discussing on Friday is we now have the first administration of the Strong Workforce Grant.
If you remember in the last budget, $150 million was appropriated for CTIG to be administrated by the Department of Education and $150 million
of a strong workforce grant was to be, has been administrated by the community colleges.
And so we're going to be looking at data after this last administration of these grants.
We're going to see where there might be places where overlapping.
It's the first time that money has been split between the Department of Education and CCC.
So,
So we will be looking at that very closely and then developing metrics along the alignment of accountability for the grant money.
So more work ahead.
And I'll just add a brief mention that, you know, we've been very busy with the budget and happy to see the investments in professional learning and other things that have come through the budget process and stand ready to be signed.
And just
Just beyond the education work that we're engaged in, I've been talking to our new Surgeon General, the first Surgeon General in California, Nadine Harris-Burke, and to the head of HHS, Chris Perry, about how we think about integrated student supports across agencies and across, you know, the domains that we all work in in our silos.
Some of this will come about as the early childhood programs get off the ground and we're thinking about, you know, really birth
through and the whole child's health and educational perspectives, but also this question about how do we support children in the state all the way through, you know, elementary and secondary school and how do we provide the kind of streamlined services that are readily accessible to schools to provide in ways that give that wraparound and integration that's so necessary.
in a state which has a very high rate of poverty among students and families and where those services are desperately needed.
So we'll talk more about that, but those efforts are beginning in the administration and it's a really helpful way to begin to think about how to accomplish some of the goals that we set in the school system.
Agenda item 15.
We have two speakers signed up, Evelyn Anderson and Rigel Massaro.
Hi.
I'm Evelyn Anderson, former trustee on the Santa Rosa City School Board, current principal at the Santa Rosa French American Charter School, parent and community member.
I just want to make you aware of the Santa Rosa French American Charter School because we hope to come forward before you in the near future regarding the CBEST testing and our teachers who come from France to provide our students with a full cultural and bilingual experience.
And again, details will be forthcoming, but I just want to say thank you in advance for considering our school.
It's a public dependent charter school that educates our students to be multiculturally aware, bi and often trilingual.
And they're preparing to work and compete in the increasingly global economy of the 21st century.
So again, we're the Santa Rosa French American Charter School, and thank you for your time.
Good afternoon, Board Chair and members, Superintendent Rajal Masar with Public Advocates.
As we shared in May, we have significant concerns shared in the letter that was just circulated about the legality of CDE's implementation of ESSA's requirement to report inequities in students' access to credentialed teachers, both in the LCAP addendum and the forthcoming state report to the U.S.
Department of Education.
Contrary to the board-adopted ESSA plan definitions, CDE is treating temporary permit and waiver holders as credentialed teachers and thus is not including them in either the ineffective or the out-of-field teacher designations.
This position contravenes the ESSA plan, its procedural history, legislative intent, and state certification law, and grossly distorts the real distribution of underprepared teachers in our schools.
We request that the department, and at the board's discretion, direction if necessary, to immediately issue clarifying guidance that permits and waivers are considered both ineffective and out of field, and grant LEAs a reasonable extension to complete and approve the records of analysis.
Thank you.
On that important note, which we are not permitted to take up because it's not agendized, we will come back to that.
I am prepared now to adjourn the July 2019 meeting of the State Board of Education.
And it is only 2.05.
Whoo!
Don't party too much.
Yeah, stay for the picture.
And then we can, then you can go party.